Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan.
Wo sind wir hier?
Wir sind im Saalbau in Bornheim in Frankfurt.
Hinter uns sind wir.
Und gleich beginnt die große Live-Show. Ich habe schon gehört, du hast dir Sommerinterviews angesehen. Aber ein bisschen anders, nämlich wie junge Menschen das machen als Twitchstream.
Die Tagesschau macht ein Tagesschau-together-Format. Dort wird das 30-Minuten-Sommerinterview in 3 Stunden gestreamt. Das heißt, da ist sehr viel Zeit, Blödsinn zu labern und junge Leute zu indoktrinieren. Falls du es noch nicht wusstest, von Bögensteuer ganz böse, klappt eh nicht, wurde aussortiert, historisch überholt und so. Wir überprüfen nachher die Argumentation.
Ich habe Clips dabei, vor allem von Taylor Lorenz. Sie setzt sich sehr stark für Free Speech ein. Und ich muss auch sagen, je mehr ich über all das nachdenke, desto mehr komme ich auch zu dem Schluss, ich bin für absolute Free Speech. Jetzt sind wir ja bekanntlich, welche, die auch immer gewarnt haben, vor Folgen soziale Medien und so weiter. Stichwort Manfred Spitzer. Oder manche Thesen von Jonathan Hyde fanden wir auch gar nicht so schlecht. Ich bin gespannt, wie du dich gleich dazu in Stellung bringen wirst. Ich habe den Eindruck, du wirst widersprechen. Aber ich glaube, es geht nicht ohne Free Speech. Und wir dürfen, um das Bild einmal zu gebrauchen, das Kind nicht mit dem Bade ausgießen. Und das geschieht gerade.
Free Speech ist nur in Amerika, Artikel 1, und auch dort nicht der einzige. Ich werde nachher ein bisschen dagegenhalten.
Okay, also wir diskutieren über Free Speech und wir beantworten Fragen aus dem Publikum, die jetzt gleich bei uns eintreffen werden.
Werden wir uns eigentlich auf Bierdeckel zugeworfen?
Ich denke, wir sammeln sie in Ruhe ein und dann werden wir uns diesen Fragen stellen. Das jedenfalls gibt es dann alles im Live-Salon, nachzuhören und zu sehen. Und wir haben auch noch eine Ankündigungsmache. Die Bücher, die wir als nächstes lesen. Wir wollen uns mit dem Thema Polarisierung beschäftigen. Und da erscheinen zwei Bücher, geradezu gleichzeitig. Also schon erschienen ist das Buch Polarisierung von Nils Kumka bei Surkamp. Der sagt offenbar, ich habe das Buch noch nicht gelesen, Polarisierung ist eigentlich gar nicht so schlecht. Man muss sie nur besser gestalten. Wir sind gespannt, was er damit meint. Und es gibt noch ein zweites Buch zur Polarisierung, das jetzt Anfang September erscheint, nämlich Verbinden statt Spalten heißt das.
Vom Bundespräsidenten?
Nein, eben von Gilda Sahabi. Und das hat mich ein bisschen überrascht, dieser Titel, da ich sie gar nicht so als die gesehen habe, die vereinen will. Aber wahrscheinlich wird sie das auf eine Art tun, die uns doch überrascht. Wir werden jedenfalls uns diese beiden Konzepte oder Theorien zur Polarisierung ansehen, denn das ist ja definitiv so. Wir leben in polarisierten Zeiten.
Ja, ich will auch, dass es mehr polarisiert ist. Ich weiß nicht genau, was die Leute da haben.
Okay, dann müssen wir gleich bei Freespeech richtig aufeinander losgehen. Ja, wir werden sehen. Jetzt erst mal einen schönen Abend bzw. wer das dann nachhört. Viel Vergnügen damit. Wir sollten aber noch ganz kurz sagen, wie man jetzt diesen Live-Sanon nachhören kann.
Man geht auf neunzwanziger.de, wir sind ein Podcast mit eigener Webseite. Mick hat keine eigene Webseite. Der sitzt hier am Bühnenrand und kriegt gleich von mir wieder einen Einlauf. Also jeder gute Podcast hat eine eigene Webseite, weil da kann man goldene Button unterbringen. Das haben wir gemacht. Das ist der Salon, da kommt man dahin. Wir präferieren wie immer Steady. Man kann den Salon aber auch bei Apple Podcast hören oder bei Patreon, wenn man da die Account schon hat oder es einem einfacher fällt. Aber bei Steady bekommt man das ganze Archiv, alle Kapitelmarken, der eigene RSS-Feed, gut, den kriegt man auch. Aktuelle Coverbilder und so weiter und so fort.
Und wir würden uns freuen, wenn ihr ein Jahresabo abschließt, denn das ist nicht nur etwas günstiger für euch, sondern auch für uns etwas günstiger, weil dann die diversen Zahlungsdienstleister, und in die Hälfte dieser ist, glaube ich, Sam Oltmann inzwischen investiert, dann ein bisschen weniger Geld bekommen, weil die Zahlung ja nur einmal jährlich erfolgt.
So is it.
Jetzt viel Vergnügen mit dem Live-Salon. Ja, es sind viele Fragen dazugekommen. Es gibt auch noch die Möglichkeit, weitere Fragen zu stellen. Aber bevor wir hier von Antworten reden, haben wir natürlich auch noch viel anderes mitgebracht. Stefan war bei den jungen Leuten bei Twitch. Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Ich war da nicht. Die waren bei mir.
Ja.
In meinem Fernseher. Man darf es nicht mehr Fernsehen sagen. Auch nicht Zuschauer und Zuschauerinnen. Sind Userinnen.
Okay.
Liebe Nutzer und Nutzerinnen. Wollen wir erstmal unser Intro hören? Zu den Fragen kann ich noch sagen. Mick, wo ist er? Mick ist da. Fernsehpodcasthörer wissen Bescheid. Mick wird alle Fragen einer strengen Qualitätskontrolle unterziehen. Ich habe ihn ein paar Sachen mitgegeben. Und danach werden wir die beantworten.
Sehr gespannt.
Okay.
Gut, dann mach doch mal, fahr mal das Intro ab. Man merkt, als das Intro erstellt wurde, hat man noch nicht darüber nachgedacht, ob man mal Live-Anstaltungen macht. Dann hätte man es vielleicht ein bisschen schmissiger.
Wer hört es typischerweise in höherer Geschwindigkeit? Das ist zu wenig. Leute, wir müssen mehr Podcast-Hörerziehung machen. Ihr müsst eure Podcasts schneller hören. Auch, weil die Podcasts dann klüger klingen. Apropos, wer weiß nicht, wo er hier gerade ist? Ich weiß, in Reihe eins sitzen mehrere Leute, die nicht wissen, wo sie sind. Sonst noch jemand? Okay, ein paar Hände. Nächste Frage ist, wer glaubt, dass das hier ein wahnsinnig kluger Podcast ist, der den Zeitgeist einfängt, die politischen Debatten richtig führt? Okay, ein paar. Ich hoffe, ihr wart nicht so sehr enttäuscht. Also ich hoffe, die Enttäuschung war nicht zu groß, als wir über Lammubus sprachen. Denn so wie letztes Jahr, als ich meinte, kurz bevor wir hier waren, keiner trinkt mehr Spezi und sich herausstellte, nein, alle trinken Spezi und ich seit einem Jahr auch, wusste ich nicht, was Labubu ist. Also das ist Labubu und Labubu sieht auch wahnsinnig, das ist ja das, was Wolfgang ausgepackt hat. Das ist das Love-Gesicht.
Ja, aber Liebe können wir doch alle brauchen. Von daher, das ist doch wunderbar.
Liebe können wir alle brauchen. Nora hat mich aufgeklärt. Also wir machen auch eigene Recherchen, aber hier vor allem in Gabor Steingart's Business, irgendwas, Investor Briefing gestern, waren die Labubus top. Eventim war flop. Und ich lese euch kurz vor, hier unten wird noch drauf hingewiesen. Diese Firma macht 1,9 Milliarden US-Dollar Umsatz. Er hat sich vervierfacht. Das ist bescheuert. Nora hat diese News aus Seattle mitgebracht. Sie war, das ist ein Foto. Amerikanerinnen gehen einkaufen, haben ihre Designer-Handtäschchen, ihr Shopping-Bag und so weiter. Und ihr seht es vielleicht, da hängt ein Labubu an dieser Tasche. Das ist eine Zusendung aus Peking von Christian. Da steht Labubu richtig groß. Weitere Eindrücke aus Peking. Also die zwei Milliarden kommen ja irgendwo her. Und das ist auch Peking. Das ist wieder Seattle. Pop Mart ist ja die Firma, die das herstellt.
Ja, bestimmt bald auch in Frankfurt.
Das ist wahnsinnig gut. Ich bin gespannt, wann wir sowas hier in Frankfurt finden. Also es ist wirklich wahnsinnig bescheuert.
Aber wir sehen doch daran so wunderbar jetzt diesen kulturellen Shift. Also wenn man mich gefragt hat vor ein paar Jahren zum Thema so Hegemonie, wer könnte die nächste Weltmacht sein, dann hat man sich natürlich wirtschaftlich oder so immer wieder auf China einigen können. Oder zumindest gibt es da doch ein gewisses Potenzial. Aber wo ich mir doch eigentlich bis vor einer Weile immer recht sicher war, war, dass weiterhin Hollywood eigentlich so eine popkulturelle Hegemonie haben wird und die USA damit. Und dann gab es natürlich schon die K-Pop Phänomene, vor allem aus Korea. Aber ich hatte mir nicht denken können, dass man also so lizenzierte Produkte mit einem solchen Hype auf einem westlichen Markt unterbringen kann, wie das Disney ja schon seit langer Zeit nicht mehr so richtig schafft. Das ist ja schon ein großer Wandel, der da vonstatten geht, der nicht zu erwarten war.
Ja, was ich vor allem erstaunlich finde, typischerweise hätte man ja gedacht, okay, wenn die ganze Softpower in Amerika abgebaut wird und in China aufgebaut wird, dann werden die uns ja wohl ihren Tom Cruise und ihre F-18, was auch immer, Flugzeuge zeigen. Stattdessen ist das das neue Hollywood. Plastikbomber.
Wir wollen uns jetzt zunächst mit einem neuen Leib- und Magenthema von mir beschäftigen.
Also Leib- und Magenthema, aber nicht neu.
Die Begeisterung ist groß, die Begeisterung ist groß für dir. Wir sprechen jetzt über Free Speech. Ich merke, dass je mehr ich mich mit dem Thema beschäftige, desto radikaler werde ich einen Free Speech anwender. Du willst mir das wahrscheinlich austreiben, Aber wir fangen erstmal so mit dem Einstieg an, und ich lasse mal alle ein bisschen im Ungewissen. Frage aber kurz in die Runde, wer kennt Lil Tay? Ganz wenige. So erging es mir auch. Lil Tay ist aber ein Internetphänomen. Wir hören jetzt mal an, wie ein YouTuber die Karriere von Lil Tay zusammenfasst.
So, Lil Tay has always been a mystery online. For those of you who don't remember, back in 2016 to 2018, there was this little girl dubbed Little Tay, who went viral after she made countless videos flexing cars, money, and designer items.
You already know what it is. Lil Tay is the youngest flexer of the century. I'm only nine years old, but I'm richer than all y'all broke haters. It's bigger than your whole entire living room, and I got four more houses. This shit costs more than your rent.
If you treat yourself like a new person, that's the real thing.
Das mag sein, aber in dieser Häufigkeit und diese Videos, die da produziert werden, dass die da in Geldscheinen badet und so was, muss ja irgendwie gelotst sein. Also es wird ja nicht so sein, dass die jetzt nicht einfach Zugang zum Internet verschafft haben und diesen Character erfunden hat. Und es gibt auch Videos, die zeigen, wie sie quasi so trainiert wird in dieser Art des Sprechens. Und das funktioniert natürlich alles nach einer Überbietungslogik, wie wir uns denken können. So musste man immer irgendwelche Pranks rausbringen. Zum Beispiel sowas.
She and her brother literally faked their own deaths to try and create some buzz around the little tape brand.
The teen rapper, whose real name is Claire Hope, and who rose to fame online in 2018, has passed away.
Once this was outed as a hoax, where they said they got hacked apparently, she would then return to her flexing, shit-talking ways.
Five years and y'all still broke. Talking all this shit when...
Ja, also dann wurde fingiert, dass sie oder der Bruder gestorben sind, und das hat natürlich wieder enorme Aufmerksamkeit generiert, und so hat man das immer weiter und weiter getrieben. Dann wurde es mal kurz ein bisschen ruhiger um Lil Tay. Dann näherte sich der 18. Geburtstag, und Folgendes geschah.
And she's once again asking, shall I remake this on my OF, if I make one on July 29th? And so she would pretty much continue with her ad campaign.
So, it's my 18th birthday on July 29th, and every male has been counting down to it, and literally telling me to drop the link the second I turn 18. Garlies, what do you think? Should I do it?
Ich kann schon mal verraten, was geschah. Natürlich hat sie einen OnlyFans-Kanal Sie hat sich einmal pünktlich zu ihrem 18. Geburtstag eröffnet, in dem sie allerdings keine Nacktbilder wohl zeigt, was natürlich auch zu heftigen Reaktionen geführt hat. Sie hat wohl mehrere Millionen innerhalb von Stunden darüber verdient und entsprechend groß ist die Empörung über dieses ganze Phänomen, aber vor allem überohnen die Fans die Plattform etc. Wir machen uns aber erstmal davon frei, also wir könnten jetzt auch gleich in die Moral Panic natürlich verfallen und ich neige dazu natürlich. Und dann habe ich aber Taylor Lorenz gehört. Wir kennen sie gut, wir haben ihr Buch Extremely Online im Podcast besprochen und für gut befunden. Und sie hat jetzt in ihrem Podcast eine neue Rubrik. Jeden Freitag gibt es den Free Speech Friday, in dem sie sich diesem Thema annimmt, weil sie sagt, Free Speech ist bedroht.
Aber was hat die junge Dame jetzt mit Free Speech zu tun?
Darauf kommen wir gleich zurück. Ich will uns erst mal selbst in diese Moral Panic versetzen. Junge Menschen im Internet und dann am Ende, wenn sie 18 sind, machen sie OnlyFans. Das kann ja nicht gesund sein und das ist auch nicht gesund. Und hier gibt es natürlich auch sehr viel an Verletzungen von Persönlichkeitsrechten angefangen, bis hin zu, wer ist eigentlich der Erziehungsberechtigte? Wie kann das alles sein? Das wären individuelle Fragen, die hier an dem Fall zu klären sind. Das interessiert uns aber heute nicht, sondern wir wollen erst mal aus dieser Moral Panic so ein bisschen rausgehen und gucken, was gerade passiert. Denn ich glaube, auch wenn ich ein kritisches Buch mit der Ulle über Influencer geschrieben habe und auch wenn wir uns kritisch beschäftigen mit den sozialen Medien und so, ist für uns ja doch die Frage, und wir gehen da gleich mal ein bisschen das durch, inwieweit ist denn die Kritik daran dahingehend, dass wir sagen, und deswegen muss es zu staatlichen Regulierungen kommen. Weil so weit man anfängt zu regulieren, naja, dann kommen ja ganz viele andere Probleme mit rein. Wir blicken erstmal nach Großbritannien. Wir hören Taylor Lawrence.
The UK's new age verification law just went into effect and it's already preventing anyone under the age of 18 from accessing information on Reddit about Israeli war crimes. This is yet another example of why these kids' online safety age verification laws are really only about one thing. Censorship.
Du guckst skeptisch?
No. Also ja, Censur steckt da drin als Potenzial. Aber ist nicht the only thing.
Genau, aber das ist ja irgendwann das Ding. Also wenn wir über, es gibt, glaube ich, viele Leute, die diese Gesetze einbringen, die es gut meinen und sagen, wir müssen die Kinder schützen. Beispielsweise eine der diversen Ex-Frauen von Gerhard Schröder, ich weiß gerade wirklich nicht welche, hatte sich seinerzeit sehr stark dafür eingesetzt in den 90er Jahren, wie man Kinder vor Gewaltfilmen schützen kann. Das hat eben dazu geführt, dass auch Kunstfilme von Monika Treuth in den SM und Feminismus vorkommt, plötzlich keine FSK-Freigabe mehr hatten und so Sachen. Das heißt, die Frage ist ja immer, wie weit führt eigentlich so ein Gesetz zu dem, was man möchte und was verunmöglicht es als Außerdem? Taylor Norns führt hier mal aus.
The law mandates age verification across all platforms that carry adult content. But, as I'm going to explain in this video, that means every single platform. Because while these laws are falsely framed as cracking down on corn, what they deem adult content is far more wide-reaching than you might think.
Denn es geht hier um Adult Content. Jetzt könnte man sagen, ja, ja, Pornografie, das müsste man ja irgendwie schützen. Aber was ist mit Plattformen, zum Beispiel wie Reddit oder Twitter, ex, schuldigung, auf denen es natürlich auch pornografische Fotos zu finden gibt? Nicht jetzt auf der Frontseite wie bei einer Porno-Seite, aber man findet sie ja. Bedeutet also auch das, verpflichtet diese Plattformen dazu, eine Age-Verification zu machen, bedeutet also, junge Menschen werden auch von diesen Plattformen ausgeschlossen. Zum Beispiel von Reddit.
Ja, was eine gute Sache ist. Also ich finde, 8-jährige, 12-jährige, 14-jährige haben da vielleicht gar nicht so viel verloren.
Aber jetzt sind wir jetzt schon wieder bei einem sehr interessanten Punkt. Du sagst jetzt 8-jährige, 12-jährige, 14-jährige. Ich habe versucht, meine Kindheit zu vergessen, aber ich erinnere mich doch insofern, als ich sagen kann, mit 8 war ich doch ziemlich anders als mit 14.
Du sowieso. Du bist ja auch eine Orchidee. Das haben wir ja schon längst gesagt.
Na ja, aber normale Kinder auch. Also wir haben ja nicht umsonst eine FSK-Freigabe, die sehr unterscheidet, was man im 8-jährigen und 14-jährigen zumutet.
Ja, aber du kennst ja auch das Internet. Du weißt ja, was auf diesen Plattformen los ist.
Definitiv. Die Frage ist, block ich damit den Zugang zu dieser Plattform oder lass es nur noch über age verification geschehen. Das heißt also nur noch über 18-Jährige.
Genau. Oder Teile dieser Plattform.
Und da wird es sehr kompliziert bei einer Plattform, die so alles Mögliche abdeckt. Also ich kann jetzt eine Seite...
Es wird nur kompliziert, wenn man sich das einreden lässt, dass es kompliziert sei.
Oder wenn man es falsch umsetzt, wie die es hier machen. Wir merken heute, es ist hier kontroverse.
This is why young people suddenly have to upload their government ID or face scan themselves to do things like listen to Spotify or watch YouTube. Every social media app, because it contains news content, is considered adult. This means that everyone, not just kids, but everyone, is now legally required in the UK to upload things like their government-issued ID, live selfies, biometric facial recognition, credit card info and more. Just to use major platforms like Reddit, Twitter, Blue Sky and thousands of independent websites.
Ich finde, das kann man nicht wollen.
Also, damit habe ich auch große Probleme. Aber das ist eben, finde ich, ein Lösungsweg, den man austauschen kann gegen sehr viel bessere Lösungswege und auch sehr viel etabliertere Lösungswege. Denn wenn ich, und ich höre ja auch viel Taylor Lawrence und hatte jetzt auch schon, wir schicken uns ja die Clips im ersten Abend vorher zu, also ich habe gestern Wolfgangs Clips geguckt, gesehen die Liste und habe sie aufbereitet und haben dann gedacht, eigentlich wollte ich doch noch schon immer mal so ein bisschen gucken, ob Taylor Lawrence nicht der neue Chef Jarvis ist, der also das Silicon Valley Ideologie-Business treibt, aber aus einer Richtung, wo man denkt damals, ah, das ist ja der Professor aus New York, der wird schon recht haben, oder jetzt eben die Aktivistin auf Nutzerseite. Ja, man muss nicht jeder Plattform, nur weil sie eventuell mal ein Nacktbild hat, seinen Personal ausweiss schicken. Bin ich auch total dafür.
Machen die aber einen Juckel?
Genau, das heißt aber noch lange nicht, dass das Problem der Altersverifikation damit einfach unlösbar ist. Und das kann man gar nicht machen. Denn wenn man zur Rewe geht, ist völlig klar, da findet eine Altersverifikation statt. Ich gehe dahin und ich muss geschäftsfähig sein. Wenn die Kassiererin sieht, ich bin irgendwie sieben, darf sie fragen, ist das denn dein Taschengeld, wie sind deine Eltern und so weiter, sofort. Also Age-Gating ist ganz normal, nur online noch nicht. Es sei denn, es geht um was. Wenn diese Seiten einfach eine Zugangsbeschränkung, so wie wir hier auch haben, man muss ein Ticket kaufen, dann sollte man dieses Ticket möglichst anonym. Und dieser eine Datenpunkt ist volljährig, darf kaufen, den kann man noch mitliefern. Das heißt noch lange nicht, dass man eine technische Lösung braucht, die gesetzlich abgesichert wird, dass jede einzelne Firma jetzt so ein Datensilo an Personalausweisen und so zusammensammelt. Und diese Differenzierung, ich bin sehr gespannt, wie es hier weitergeht, die fehlt mir bei Taylor Lorenz immer.
Beziehungsweise man kann ja ein anderes Unternehmen einsetzen zur Verifizierung. Aber die Frage ist dann, welches wird es sein? Auch der Name wird natürlich nachher fallen. Ja, aber nicht jeder hat der Apple Geräte und der Apple ist natürlich daran interessiert. Ich würde im Übrigen in der These schon widersprechen, aber das werden wir gleich nochmal hören, dass Taylor Lorenz jetzt quasi so Silicon Valley Ideologie verbreitet. Ich würde sagen, der Silicon Valley hat eine neue Ideologie und sie ist eng verknüpft mit den Interessen der jeweiligen Regierung. Wir haben es ja schon bei The Technological Republic gesehen. Denn um welche Inhalte geht es denn hier noch? Weil wir haben jetzt alle so die Vorstellung, ja, gute Hardcore-Pornografie, dass die nicht Kindern zugänglich gemacht werden soll, ist ja logisch. Aber...
Like all of these terrible online censorship bills, the Online Safety Act claims that it's about protecting children from the evils of pornographic and adult content. But immediately after it went into effect, platforms began classifying nearly all breaking news footage, investigative journalism, political protest material and reporting on the ongoing atrocities around the world as explicit, harmful and adult content, blocking anyone under the age of 18 from accessing it.
Tote in Gaza sind adult content. Findet für Menschen unter 18 Jahren nicht mehr statt. Ich frage mich auch, was das für eine Vorstellung ist, dass man dann so mit 18 plötzlich irgendwie mit der Welt konfrontiert ist, die die ganze Zeit einem verschwert wurde. Also ich meine, junge Leute finden natürlich Mittel und Wege. Auch das hören wir hier.
Four out of the top five free apps on the UK Apple Store right now are VPN services, as people are desperately trying to circumvent these filters and access crucial news information. But many systems have ways to detect VPNs. And the government will likely crack down on VPN use as well.
Ja.
Also, statt eine gute Technologie aufzubauen, eine gute abzubauen, das ist wirklich eine sehr schlechte Folge. Aber vielleicht kann man trotzdem mal sagen, das was die da versuchen, das ist ja jetzt hier...
UK.
Ah, diese UK-Besgründung.
Wir kommen noch zu den USA.
Die amerikanischen Versionen sind ja jetzt das erste Mal überhaupt, dass man versucht, Social Media zu reglementieren. Und es sind ja auch bipartisan Aktionen. Also das ist ein bisschen wie damals bei der Datenschutz-Grundverordnung, als es hieß und das war dann Jeff Jarvis Hochzeit. Nee, das Internet ist noch so neu. Wollen wir das wirklich schon durch Regulierung wieder? Wir wissen da noch gar nicht, in welche Richtung sich das entwickelt. Es könnte ja auch eine gute sein und so. Und in Amerika, klar, die sind jetzt spät dran. Aber das, was wir hier besprechen für den angelsächsischen Bereich, ist sozusagen die erste Welle überhaupt mal ernsthaft regulatorisch einzugreifen.
Und dann aber gleich so stark. Und bedeutet natürlich auch so eine Konsolidierung der Mainstream-Medien, wie Taylor Norr uns betont.
And also to be able to gain access to information outside government propaganda and the mainstream media, which, let's be honest, mostly regurgitates government propaganda. These child safety laws limit young people's opportunities for critical thinking and civic understanding. And they isolate young people from global perspectives.
Die sollen sich nämlich nicht über den Ostkonflikt auf TikTok informieren. Und ja, es gibt natürlich viel Scheißinhalt zu diesem Thema auf TikTok. Aber es gibt eben auch sehr guten Inhalt, der nicht repräsentiert ist, wenn man sagt, ich versuche mich mit Funk zu informieren oder so.
Aber das, was Sie jetzt sagte, klang im Wortlaut schon ziemlich nach Mark Zuckerberg.
Nee, Mark Zuckerberg ist ja inzwischen ganz auf der Schiene, wir helfen euch, damit ihr die Age-Verification machen könnt.
Genau, der macht jetzt gerade den Ordnern, Regulierung, ja, ich weiß, wie man das machen sollte und so.
Aber 20 Jahre lang hieß es, sind wir nicht an dem Punkt, wo wir jetzt quasi, wenn Sie jetzt die Zensoren werden, dann müssen wir doch jetzt sagen, wir sind jetzt für Freespeech.
Also es gab ja auch mal eine Zeit vor dem Internet, in der Jugendliche auch Kontakt mit der Welt aufgenommen haben. Aber schwieriger. Ja klar, schwieriger. Und danach gab es Internet und dann hieß es, guckt euch mal die drei Fälle an, da haben welche ihre Herzens-Community gefunden und 30 weitere sind einfach abgedriftet und wir haben Talks über Rabbit-Holes gemacht.
Ja gut, aber ist das schlimm?
Rabbit-Holes, Verschwörungstheorie, der ganze Kram?
Ja, aber es gibt ja auch gute Rabbit-Holes. Also man kann sich jetzt zum Beispiel auch mit dem Marxismus beschäftigen.
Orchidee.
Nein, also es sind doch ganz viele.
Welcher 14-jährige sucht sich denn eine Marxistische Online-Community?
Nein, aber dann sitzen hier sieben. Hände hoch. Nein, aber dann sitzen hier 700 Orchideen. Also die auch jetzt vielleicht nicht an Marx nur interessiert sind, aber an zum Beispiel Freiheitsrechten durch Programmierung, durch IT und all das. Auch das ist ein großes Thema. Also ich will, ich wundere mich, dass sich alles so verändert hat. Ich weiß, wenn normalerweise Regierungen sagen, dass gewisse Inhalte nicht gut sind für Kinder und Jugendliche. Also Kinder, Jugendliche wird ja alles so zusammen gedacht, wo ich auch sage, naja, ob mal 17 oder 7 ist, das wirklich ein sehr fundamentaler Unterschied. Und wenn man dann sagt, die sollen nicht zu sehr politisiert werden und nicht diese harmful content sehen, dann denke ich hier an eine gute Freundin von Angela Merkel, einst Annegret Kramp-Karrenbauer. Wir hören uns noch einmal Ihre Reaktion auf das Rezo-Video an, Zerstörung der CDU. Und danach gab es ja noch so einen Influencer-Aufruf, Weltallern nicht die CDU.
Anmutung, die dort sozusagen mit Blick auf die CDU, was hat ja auch CSU und hat auch SPD betroffen, die dort zum Ausdruck gebracht wird, wie sagen wir mal, die im Grunde genommen allen Mitgliedern gegenüber signalisiert, alle, die sich bei CDU, CSU, SPD engagieren, die sind entweder sozusagen irgendwie minder belittelt oder versuchen, die Zukunft dieses Landes zu zerstören, empfinde ich wirklich als ein Schlag ins Gesicht von Menschen, die sich zum Großteil neben ihrem Beruf ehrenamtlich für dieses Land engagieren. Als die Nachricht kam, dass sich eine ganze Reihe von Duotubern zusammengeschlossen haben, um einen Aufruf zu starten, einen Wahlaufruf gegen CDU und SPD, habe ich mich gefragt, was wäre eigentlich in diesem Land los, wenn eine Reihe von 70 Zeitungsredaktionen zwei Tage vor der Wahl erklärt hätten, wir machen einen gemeinsamen Aufruf, wählt bitte nicht CDU und SPD. Es wäre klare Meinungsmache vor der Wahl gewesen. Und ich glaube, es hätte eine muntere Diskussion in diesem Land ausgelöst. Und die Frage stellt sich schon mit Blick auf das Thema Meinungsmache, was sind eigentlich Regeln aus dem analogen Bereich und welche Regeln gelten eigentlich für den digitalen Bereich? Ja oder nein? Das ist eine sehr grundlegende Frage, über die wir uns unterhalten werden. Und zwar nicht nur wir in der CDU und mit der CDU, sondern ich bin mir ganz sicher, in der gesamten medienpolitischen und auch demokratietheoretischen Diskussion der nächsten Zeit wird das eine Rolle spielen. Und deswegen werden wir diese Diskussion auch sehr offensiv angehen.
Ja, ich verstehe Ihre Wut darauf, aber das Internet hat ja Recht.
Sie will ja hier eigentlich eine Zensurmaßnahmeankündigung sagen, das geht nicht. Und ich meine, wann hat es das je gegeben, dass große Zeitungsverleger parteiisch sind? Ja, das gibt es natürlich gar nicht. Ja, nur diese Influencer sind das immer. Wir hören jetzt, was Tilly Lawrence uns erzählen kann, über den No-Fakes Act in den USA.
There's a bill right now in Congress, that if you didn't know any better, sounds great. It's called the No Fakes Act, and it claims to protect you from deep fakes on the web. Representative Maria Salazar from Florida said this when announcing the bill. Quote, in this new era of AI, we need real laws to protect real people. The No Fakes Act is simple and sacred. You own your identity.
Klingt ja erst mal gut. Bedeutet aber auch, wenn jetzt jemand in der AI ein Foto von mir nimmt, und da irgendwas modifiziert, das publiziert, könnte ich dagegen vorgehen. Wollen wir das?
Ja, also in dem Fall ja. Denn wir können uns das alles noch nicht so richtig vorstellen.
Aber dann können wir auch Memes verbieten.
Genau. Das Problem ist so ein bisschen...
Dann hat der Meme-Kanal ein Problem.
Yeah, also wir hatten, also wir haben in Deutschland eine Geschichte aus Volkszählung-Urteilen. Darf mal jemand bei dir klopfen und fragen, ob im Kinderzimmer noch jemand wohnt oder das Kind schon ausgezogen ist. Das war kurz vor Volksaufstand. Also wahrscheinlich der größte Protest jemals in Westerland. Also wir haben das Recht am eigenen Bild, das ganz vehement durchgesetzt wird in diesen ganzen Communities bis hin zu, wir schließen uns jetzt vier Tage im Hamburger Kongresszentrum ein und darf niemanden fotografieren. Jeder, der irgendwann mein Bild postet, fliegt sofort von der Veranstaltung. Und das wurde lange belächelt in dieser Strenge und jetzt irgendwie nicht mehr. Denn Leute stellen ganz schön häufig fest, ich bin digital dupliziert worden und zwar auf eine Art und Weise, die ich nicht mag. Nun braucht man wahrscheinlich dafür Kinder in der Schule, um das mitzukriegen. Wir wissen ja technisch.
Nee, das kriege ich ja selbst mit meinen eigenen Sachen mit.
Also bei dir ist es relativ harmlos. Es wird halt ein politisches Meme gemacht. Aber wenn du in der Schule nicht weißt, warum die Klasse gerade über dich lacht. Weil nämlich wieder einer so ein Bild erstellt hat, wo du nackt drauf bist und so weiter. Und das zieht sich dann durch die Schule. Man kann wirklich nicht erkennen, ist es jetzt ein Fake oder nicht. Und ich sage ja immer wieder, wir gehen auch ins Kino und fangen an zu weinen, nur weil der Regisseur so klug war. Und wir wissen, es ist ein Drehbuch, das ist ausgedacht, das ist Schauspiel. Und trotzdem ergreift es uns. Also das, was wir heute schon und demnächst als Fake-Bilder sehen werden, wird auf einer sehr neuen und aber sehr wirkungsvollen Weise als echt im Gehirn verarbeitet. Obwohl alle wissen, dass es nicht echt ist. Und dagegen brauchen wir ja auch einen echten Schutz.
Ja, aber wenn wir diesen Schutz haben, dann können wir eigentlich gar keine Memes mehr produzieren. Also dann können wir auch nicht mehr sagen...
Du kannst es ja zulassen. Du kannst ja sagen, ich Wolfgang M. Schmitt, solange ich einen Anzug anhabe, auf dem Meme ist alles erlaubt.
Ja, aber sobald ich jetzt zum Beispiel von Trump ein lustiges Foto mache, wird das ein Problem. Wir hören hier mal was Kate Wren sagt vom Center for Democracy.
The way the bill is constructed, it's supposed to be a protection for everyone. But it's mostly going to wind up, as far as I can tell, benefiting public figures, famous people and gigantic rights holders, like record companies and movie studios.
Wer da in Fankreisen sein Star Wars generate macht, der ist draußen.
Ja, aber bleiben wir mal bei Trump. Über Jahrzehnte war klar, wenn über Donald Trump geschrieben wird, muss es wahr sein. Und dann gab es sehr viel journalistische Codexer und so weiter. Und jemand, der die nicht einhalten konnte, bei dem war auch klar, der hat eh keine Druckerpresse, ist im Grunde egal. Das haben wir dann irgendwann bei Bildern gehabt. Und ich denke mir, ich kann mir sehr gut eine Welt vorstellen, in der wir einfach sagen, wenn wir Donald Trump auf einem Bild sehen, darf man durchaus den Anspruch haben, das muss so tatsächlich stattgefunden haben. Nur weil jemand eine gute Idee hatte und es sich heute leicht prompten lässt, heißt das noch lange nicht, dass deswegen feuerfrei ist.
Aber dann gibt es keine AI Memes mehr.
Dann gibt es keine AI Memes.
It's a part of powerful people like politicians and public figures who don't like it when people criticize them or make fun of them.
Ja, also wer hat denn?
Aber wir können doch nicht, dann ist ja einfach das Internet halbtot.
Genau.
Aber warum finden wir das gut? Darum können wir nicht sagen. Genau, aber das schützt ja auch wieder nicht normale Leute. Um die geht es natürlich um allerwenigsten. Sondern es ist ja so, dass Donald Trump ja selbst gesagt hat, ich glaube, hier ist noch ein Clip dazu, in dem, ach nee, es geht um Nachahmung und Ähnlichkeit, ja. Also, wo beginnt auch dann, dass man sagt, man, der sieht aber schon nicht ganz so aus wie ich, aber der ist schon mir entlehnt. Und dann kann ich auch sagen.
Und dies ist, wenn man so will, auch ein Strah.
Jetzt können wir es.
But the way the bill is structured, if you think it kind of looks like you, you do have an incentive to file a claim under this, because the way the bill is structured, it's almost certain to come down. And that's what you want. That's the result that you want. And users are very unlikely, the users who created whatever has been taken down are very unlikely to have access to the money it would take to file the lawsuit to put it back.
Ja, also ich sag mal so, du hast jetzt gemeint, da geht's nicht um normale Leute. Ich würd sagen, wir gehen jetzt mal in eine wohlwollende Herangehensweise auf dieses Gesetz. Und ich würd sagen, alle Menschen haben jetzt grundsätzlich ein Recht darauf, Ich glaube, es geht um den Aufschluss auf die Menschen, die nicht gefaket zu erscheinen, vor allem nicht, wenn sie es nicht selber machen. Wenn dann Gerichte später feststellen, naja, Moment mal, also dieser Typ, der ist auf Instagram seit zehn Jahren nur mit dem Filter unterwegs und jetzt hat jemand anders mal ein Filter auf ihn gelegt, gegen Filter an sich kann er ja nicht traben.
Aber Karikaturen sind ja auch erlaubt.
Ja, genau. Also Karikaturen sind erlaubt, aber nur, wenn die Personen im Öffentlichen und so weiter.
Aber es geht ja hier wirklich um so einen Schutz für öffentliche Leute, dass ich sagen kann, nee, mahne ich ab, hole ich mir einen Anwalt, gefällt mir nicht. So, dass ich Nancy Pelosi bin nicht einverstanden mit der Darstellung, gehe dagegen vor. Und dann sind wir ja in einen Bereich angekommen, wo man auch sich da fragen muss. Also ich finde es interessant, weil der gerade liberale, linksliberale Diskurs über die Trump-Regierung ist, es ist fünf vor Faschismus. Zugleich haben wir hier mehrere Bipartisan-Gesetze, die durchgebracht werden, also von Republikanern und Demokraten zusammen, die das Internet regulieren. Dann würde ich doch sagen, ok, also irgendwas stimmt jetzt nicht. Also entweder ist Trump gar nicht so schlimm, man kann wunderbar mit denen zusammenarbeiten und traut ihnen sogar zu, dass sie vernünftig regulieren, oder man sagt sich, nee, es ist fünf vor Faschismus, aber dann muss man ja gegen diese Gesetze sein.
Also was mir bei Taylor Lorenz immer fehlt, sie geht so sehr auf diesen, aber was würde Trump aus diesem Gesetz machen? Und da würde ich erstmal sagen, das ist mir egal. Trump macht eh was er will. Wir müssen jetzt nicht über Donald Trump reden. Wenn er das Gesetz missbraucht, um sich selber aus dem Internet zu tilgen, warte, kann er das versuchen. Und dann gucken wir mal, wie die Gesellschaft sich darauf regelt. Dieses Gesetz, no fake, das geht erstmal, also das hat die Zielsetzung, wir müssen 16-jährige Mädels vor fake AI-Revenge-Porn schützen. Und ein Gesetz, das Donald Trump in Ketten legt, weil angeblich über noch so viele Leute nicht verstehen, wie durchgeknallter er ist, wo ich mir denke, na doch, so langsam haben es alle verstanden. Ein Gesetz muss dieses Problem, das dieses Gesetz lösen möchte, lösen, unabhängig davon, was Donald Trump aus diesem Gesetz macht.
Aber nicht unabhängig von dem, was es sonst noch für das gesamte Hintergrund bedeutet.
Aber wir brauchen eine Lösung für dieses grundlegende Problem.
Ja, aber wir können auch nicht Ausgangssperre um neun Uhr verhängen, nur weil abends sehr viele Verbrechen auf der Straße stattfinden. Würde man auch nicht sagen.
So weit reicht das Gesetz ja auch nicht.
Wir erinnern uns, wir springen noch mal ins Jahr 2019, wir erinnern uns an folgende Proteste.
Und dies ist, wenn man so will, auch ein Streit in der Familie. Nur dass hier die Jungen gegen die Alten rebellieren. Die Generation digital gegen die Generation analog. So jedenfalls sehen es die vielen, vor allem jungen Leute, die in diesen Tagen auf die Straße gehen, um gegen neue europäische Regeln im Internet zu protestieren. Gegen die so verhassten Upload-Filter. Und damit meinen sie jene Schranken, die bestimmte Inhalte im Netz im Vorhinein aussortieren sollen. Und die für die Demonstranten nichts weniger sind als Zensur. Jan Koch.
Wir wollen keinen KVG-Seitzen.
Auf Kölns Straßen gegen Artikel 13 der EU-Urheberrechtsreform. Save the Internet. Die Bewegung wird immer größer. Nachdem online bereits knapp 5 Millionen EU-Bürger eine entsprechende Petition unterschrieben haben.
Das ist alles vorbei. Also ich finde das so interessant, dass wesentlich kleinere Maßnahmen echt global richtig viel Proteststürme hervorgeholt haben. Und jetzt ist ja einfach schweigend im Walse.
Das ist Zensursular. Dieses Gesetz kam nie. Wir haben bis heute keine Upload-Filter.
Auch wegen dieser Proteste.
Und Ursula von der Leyen ist immer noch verärgert, dass das in ihrer Biografie drin steht.
Genau, aber wegen dieser Proteste. Und heute haben wir gar nicht mehr die Proteste. Gucken wir uns ein anderes Gesetz noch an. Den Take it Down Act.
The stated goal of the Take it Down Act is to combat the sharing of non-consensual intimate images, NCII, what you might know as revenge corn. This includes things like AI-generated nude deepfakes and other explicit imagery shared without a person's consent. So cracking down on something like this seems great, right? Sadly, that is not what this law does, nor is it what this law is actually about. What the Take It Down Act actually does is make it so that anyone at any time can get any content posted about them online that they don't like taken off the Internet within 48 hours, no questions asked.
Auch hier ist natürlich das Anliegen richtig. Nur wenn ich ein Gesetz mache, bei dem die Plattformen nach 48 Stunden reagiert haben müssen, und das wird sonst sehr teuer, wenn die natürlich Performer sagen, na ja, ich gebe mich jetzt nicht mit einer Kontrolle ab, ich nehme einfach das runter. Und das geht dann bis, also sie führen das dann aus, bis dahin, dass da irgendwas in einem Wikipedia-Artikel über mich steht oder sonst irgendwo auf einer Seite. Ich will das nicht. Und kann dann da entsprechend mit diesem Take-it-down-Act vorgehen, weil der natürlich nicht nur impliziert Revenge-Porn.
Ja, aber dazu eine Analogie. Also wenn ich die Polizei hole und sage, hier ist Gefahren voll zu, kommt die ja und handelt. Und wenn sich danach herausstellt, dass ich die Polizei veralbert habe, wird es ja für mich ziemlich teuer und unangenehm. Und so könnte man so ein Gesetz auch, denn ich denke, könnte man ja, bin ich sehr dafür, das so zu machen, aber leider ist es nicht so konstruiert. Also aus dem Gefahr im Verzug kommen wir ja nicht raus. Das ist ja das, was im Internet wirklich fehlt, dass wenn die Hütte gerade brennt, man einfach handeln kann. Bislang war es ja so, du weißt gar nicht, wo du anrufen kannst. Also Facebook hatte in Europa jahrzehntelang gar keine Adresse, bis dann die DSGVO kam und sagte, in jedem Land müsst ihr zumindest mal einen Ansprechpartner haben und so. Und zumindest, und das gilt dann auch für beide Seiten, also diejenigen, die einen Anspruch haben, dass etwas gelöscht wird. Und diejenigen, die sagen, ich habe das zu Recht hochgeladen, da hat mich jemand. Und dann kann man aus Fächern, aus wirtschaftlichen Gründen, aus politischen Gründen und so weiter zensieren. Und da kann man ja durchaus nachträglich ein paar Spannungen einbauen, die dich zweimal überlegen lassen, ob du gegen Sachen vergisst.
Also Becker Branham sagt Folgendes.
Sure, so the Take it Down Act is a bill that was led by Senators Ted Cruz and Amy Klobuchar, that intends to address something called non-consensual intimate imagery or NCII. So imagine that you've taken an intimate picture of yourself to share with a partner, and then the partner shares it without your permission elsewhere. That's real NCII and that's been a problem for a long time. But given the new and ubiquitous access that people have to general artificial intelligence, sadly what we're seeing is the proliferation of AI-generated NCII. So people can now with that really powerful technology actually take clothed images of people and create nude images of them to which they never consented. Certainly either to create or distribute.
Auch hier haben wir wieder, also da ist Tür und Tor geöffnet für so vieles. Also ich sehe ja das konkrete Problem. Ich würde ja nicht sagen, naja, ist halt so. Aber wenn man Gesetze so baut, dann habe ich den Eindruck, und das erinnert mich an die Filmsensor der 80er Jahre, die ja sehr stark von republikanischer Seite in Großbritannien mit Thatcher und in Deutschland mit Helmut Kohl umgesetzt wurde, dass man natürlich die ganze Zeit sagte, die Kinder werden nur noch mit Gewalt indoktriniert und dann werden sie zur Amok läufeln und so weiter. Wir kennen das auch noch mal aus den Computerspielendiskursen. Und daraufhin hat man dann eine Zensur in Gang gesetzt, so da FSK-Erhöhungen, Filme indiziert und so weiter, das auf diesem Weg gemacht, weil eine Zensur findet ja in dem Sinne nicht statt, dass man plötzlich sagt, man muss also den Zugang zu einer gewissen Kunst auch versperren, beispielsweise. Und genau das sind diese Fälle, dass man also das ernste und auch wichtige Anliegen verwendet, um damit ganz anders zu machen. Also das passiert ja auch auf einer EU-Ebene. Wir haben das ja auch schon mal angedeutet. Ich kann natürlich nicht leugnen, dass Putin irgendwelche Bot-Armeen hat. Die Frage ist nur, mache ich jetzt das Internet selbst zu so einem unfreien Ort, dass ich zwar die Bot-Armeen bekämpft habe, zugleich aber auch die Meinungsfreiheit erheblich eingeschränkt habe?
Ja, am Ende braucht man das Gesetz, dass man lebt, damit man es zehn Jahre lang rechts und links zusammenklagt. Hier ist auch interessant, das ist eine Gesetzesinitiative von Amy Klobuchar und Ted Cruz. Bei der einen würde ich ja sagen, kann man die Gefahr losmachen, Klobuchars zu vertrauen. Bei Ted Cruz würde ich sagen, niemals, egal was.
Ja, also ich will das wirklich sagen. Würden wir jetzt sagen, das ist ja mal ein schönes Gesetz, das Robert Habeck und Maximilian Kratz zusammen gemacht haben oder so. Also würde man ja nicht sagen.
Aber so wäre das, ja.
Ja.
Wir springen vielleicht ein bisschen zu, ich glaube diesem, das ist ein bisschen schnell zu erkennen. Gucken wir, ob es das ist.
And do the platforms do anything to make sure and verify?
Wir gehen noch eins weiter.
And do the president himself preview this for us? For decades, content creators have fought against oppressive copyright restrictions on online content. Copyright claims are often wielded by powerful corporations to take down videos, suppress criticism or stifle parody through rigid restrictions on online speech. But now a troubling shift is unfolding. A prominent YouTuber has begun using copyright lawsuits to silence other creators' speech and commentary on his content.
Ja, das ist sehr interessant. Ich habe, also seit zehn Jahren mache ich jetzt Podcasts und das war von Anfang an mit Clips. Auf warmen Podcasts, Fernsehpodcasts, wir. Ich habe schon tausendmal die Frage bekommen, Stefan, wie macht ihr das mit dem Copyright? Später irgendwie so Clips von ProSieben, von irgendwelchen Influencers, von irgendwas und so. Dann sage ich jedes Mal, wir haben noch niemals was gehört.
Das ist Fair Use eigentlich.
Fair Use gibt es in Deutschland gar nicht. Das ist eigentlich, in Deutschland ist so ein bisschen ein Mischmasch aus, Zitatrecht, aber nur, wenn du es ausreichend kommentierst und so. Ich kam noch nie in die Verlegenheit, das zu thematisieren. Also ich frage mich, ob es hier überhaupt eine Regelungslücke gibt. Also bei ökonomischen Sachen.
Es gab ja durchaus schon auch Prozesse darum, wie viel öffentlich-rechtliches Material Leute, die das kommentieren, verwenden dürfen und so. Aber das ist natürlich alles sehr uneinheitlich. Nur, was wir jetzt ja erleben ist, dass plötzlich die Creator selbst anfangen, sich zu zensieren, wenn sie die Möglichkeit sehen, dass eine Meinung dadurch unterdrückt werden kann. Also das ist ja eben ein sehr kurzer Weg. Man hat vielleicht sogar bei YouTube einen Partner, mit dem man, also jemandem vertraut ist bei YouTube, dem man kommunizieren kann. Und dann wird da jemand gestrikt. Und wenn man zwei oder drei Strikes hat, dann wird der Kanalgeschwert für jemanden nicht mehr statt. Das heißt, die Schere der anderen Content-Creator sitzt natürlich dann schon relativ tief im Kopf. And I have to say that again a little bit. Ich hatte bis zu einem gewissen Punkt Respekt vor Rolf Poschert. Als er wirklich noch bereit war zu sagen, wir lassen alle Meinungen stattfinden. Ich erinnere mich an einen wirklich sehr radikalen Artikel von Stavros Zizek zu Assange. Und der wurde in der Welt ganzheitlich abgedruckt. Und ich glaube, das wäre fast keiner Zeitung, keiner Konservative möglich gewesen. All das. Und dann fing aber irgendwann Wolf Poschert an, auf Twitter Leute zu denunzieren. Also irgendwie zu schreiben, hier der Comedian oder der Reporter hat hier das gerade getwittert. Guckt euch das mal an, liebe Arbeitgeber, WDR oder NDR oder sonst was. Und als diese Denunziation anfing, und das wurde ja dann immer größer und wird dann von allen Seiten gemacht, da war das für mich vollkommen aus, weil dann habe ich gemerkt, okay, das ist kein Liberaler. Weil für mich bedeutet ein Liberales auch sein. Es war genauso wie bei Stragg Zimmermann, die dann irgendwann, wenn da so verrückte Protester oder vielleicht auch sehr ernstzunehmende Protester auftauchte, fragte, nennen sie mir mal ihren Arbeitsplatz. Das geht sie einfach nichts an, wo diese Leute arbeiten. Wir haben das auch von linker Seite mit unter. Man sollte sich nicht allzu sehr freuen, wenn da der Compact-Chef im Bademantel morgens rausgezerrt wird. Das kann auch die nächste linke Zeitung treffen. Also ich bin da sehr, sehr skeptisch inzwischen. Und glaube, man muss, wenn man wirklich einen liberalen Punkt machen will, sagen, ich halte das aus. Ich halte das aus. Und man kann nicht in dieses Denunzieren reinkommen. Und das findet aber jetzt hier bei YouTube statt.
I think this moment marks a potential turning point in online expression. These legal attacks that were once used almost exclusively by powerful media companies are now being leveraged by big content creators to attack smaller content creators that they don't like.
Das ist etwas, was wir glaube ich jetzt noch vielfach erleben werden. Wir haben ja schon gesehen, wie da diese ganzen Debatten um Kuchen, TV und so ständig irgendwelche Prozesse geführt wurden. Das wird jetzt immer weiter zunehmen und ist natürlich eine Einschränkung von Meinungsfreiheit.
Da gibt es jetzt Content Creator, die ihre Sachen bei Content ID anmelden, sodass sie dann andere...
Also nur die eigentlich finden Content Creator ist ja gut, wenn es Reaction Videos gibt, weil das die Popularität erhöht. Aber manche Reaction Videos sind vielleicht dann doch nicht genehm, weil sie zu kritisch sind. Und da versuchen sie dann mit Strikes bei YouTube dagegen vorzugehen.
Ja, aber klar habe ich jetzt gerade gesagt, in Deutschland habe ich das noch nie gehört, dass es das so gab und ich habe es selber nicht erlebt. Und ich könnte mir aber vorstellen, dass es das auch aus urheberrechtlich habender Seite so wenig gibt, weil die wissen, vor Gericht wäre es ziemlich schwer, Stefan Schulz zu verbieten, eine Ingo Zamparoni-Moderation zu spielen.
Ja, aber wir wissen ja, wie ein Schüchterum funktioniert. Bei dir würde das jetzt nicht so einfach funktionieren, du würdest sagen, ich fechte das mal aus, gucken wir mal. Aber jetzt stell dir vor, da ist der Content Creator, der gerade einen YouTube-Kanal hat, vielleicht sich freut über 5000 Abonnenten. Und dann kommt so ein lustiger Anwaltsbrief. Ich habe einmal einen bekommen, da ging es aber nicht um einen Guri-Bereichs-Streit. Und da stehen halt 17 Anwälte auf dem Briefkopf. Und eine Unterlassungserklärung. Und dann ist nur, weil du dann jemanden kennst, der dir sagt, du unterschreibst dich auf keinen Fall, hast du dich dann da nochmal raus, damit du weißt plötzlich, welche Drohkulissen natürlich Leute mit Kapital aufmachen können. Kommen wir zum Kids Online Safety Act.
Das ist amerikanisch, ne?
Amerikanisch, wieder.
Welcome back to Free Speech Friday. Today I want to talk to you guys about one of the most dangerous laws in Congress right now. It's called the Kids Online Safety Act and it was recently reintroduced by a bipartisan group of lawmakers. But it's being heavily pushed by the Democrats. It's a law that claims to make kids safer online. But please don't let the name fool you, because this law would give the government unprecedented power to censor speech across the entire Internet in the name of protecting kids.
Ari Cohn, Anwalt für Persönlichkeitsrechte, sagt, So the law includes something that's called a duty of care.
And it requires social media platforms basically to protect people against certain kinds of harms like anxieties, suicidal ideations, eating disorders, things like that. That requires platforms to look at content and say this is going to cause someone harm. And if it is, what they're going to do is they are going to stop kids from seeing it because they could get in trouble if it causes some kind of damage. Or even the government thinks that it might.
Das scheint mir eins zu eins die amerikanische Zensursolar-Diskussion zu sein, Upload-Filter. Ist das so neu, dass wir jetzt noch sagen können, wir warten ab? Oder ist das kurz vor Beschluss?
Das scheint ziemlich weit gedient zu sein und würde zum Beispiel folgendes bedeuten.
LGBT content. There is a contingent on the right that thinks that kids are turning trans just because they read things on the internet. Say the Attorney General of the United States sends a letter to Facebook saying, this is harmful material for children. What's Facebook going to do? They're going to tailor the content recommendation system so that it excludes anything related to being transgender whatsoever because that is the safest thing for them to do so nobody can say you're causing kids harm. Which means, you're not gonna see any trans-related content if you're a minor. Which means, if you are trans, you might think you are all alone.
Also, 17 content nur noch ab 18 dann.
Ich kann mich noch drin erinnern, wir haben das auch besprochen. Es waren die Corona Lockdowns. Alle Eltern haben so ein bisschen festgestellt, Homeschooling funktioniert nicht. Also, Schule ist einfach ausgefallen. Plus plötzlich so zehn Jahre Veronleinung innerhalb von zwei Wintern. Und dann kam diese Facebook-Files, Wistleblowerin, genau, diese Facebook-Files, wo vor allem klar war, dass Instagram selbst diese Forschung gemacht hat, wenn man sie liest, die ihnen auf die Füße fällt. Und dann hat man sich ja immer gefragt, was passiert jetzt in Amerika? Was kommt daraus? Eine Zensursular-Debatte wäre natürlich das Schlechteste, denn wie gesagt, die Probleme, die in den Titeln der Gesetze drinstehen, Kids Online Safety, sind ja da. Und Taylor Lorenz, ich habe bisher, sie hat ja heute Morgen auch wieder ein Podcast gemacht zu Thema. Ich höre da zu wenig konstruktive Wände.
Das stimmt. Also konstruktiv hat sie nicht viele anzubieten. Sie ist jetzt die Mahnerin geworden. Wir springen mal eins vor in den Clips.
And the problem with all of these kids' bills so far is that they treat minors as a monolith. They treat them as a big group that all have the same interests and the same mental state, the same capacity. And it requires them to treat them all the same. But different kids, particularly with respect to, say, a 14 year old versus a 17 year old, have different reactions, different experiences, different ways they manage and cope with different content. And even within the same age range, different kids are different. They have different life experiences.
Auch das wirst du als Vater noch besser bestätigen können als ich. Dass das so ist. Und auch die Frage ist ja, von wem will man was jetzt gerade beschützen? Also ich zum Beispiel habe sehr früh Filme geguckt, die ich nicht hätte sehen sollen. Jetzt nicht was so schmutziges, sondern mehr so Hitchcock. Ja, aber sehr jungen Jahren. Ich glaube, ich habe 11 oder 12 Jahren Marni geguckt. Ein Film über eine Kleptomane, eine Vergewaltigung und so weiter. Das ist jetzt nicht ganz das, was Elfjährige sollten. Aber es hat mir nicht geschadet. Bin Filmkritiker geworden.
Ja, sehr gut. Diese FSK-Einteilung in 6, 12, 16, 18 ist ja auch nicht verkehrt, denn die ist mittlerweile so eingeschliffen, dass jeder, selbst wenn man noch in der Programmzeitschrift nachschlägt und dann sieht A16, Mist, meine Tochter ist 14, dann lässt man sie trotzdem mitgucken. Ja, also diesen Graubereich gibt es dann. Aber ich würde erst mal sagen, für so ein Gesetz, gut, er sagt jetzt zwischen 7 und 14, wird er nicht differenziert. Ein Gesetz, das einfach pauschal 6, 12, 16, 18 macht, ist nicht allzu verkehrt. Denn ja, Kinder unterscheiden sich, aber.
Gewisse Pauschalisierung muss man ja vornehmen. Das machen wir auch beim Führerschein. Da würde ich sagen, da sind manche mit 40 eigentlich noch nicht in der Lage, ein Auto zu steuern. Und werden es auch niemals lernen. Und trotzdem können sie dann fahren. Okay, aber generell ist es natürlich problematisch, das alles über einen Kamm zu schernen. Wir springen zu einem weiteren Clip.
Well, you get a lot of them from the moral panic pieces, as you said. And a lot of it is also Jonathan Haidt. His book, The Anxious Generation, kind of put it into the mainstream of like pop psychology, basically. Even though none of that evidence is causal, it's all correlational.
Vielleicht haben wir uns auch doch ein bisschen verrückt machen lassen.
Nein.
Von den Leuten wie Jonathan Hyde, vielleicht auch Franz Spitzer.
Ich sehe es ja als individuelles Problem, die Aufmerksamkeit wird immer schlechter. Wir sehen natürlich auch, dass es sehr viel Einsamkeit und was weiß ich alles produziert. Aber zugleich, wenn man davon ausgeht, also das ist ja erstmal eine Anrede für mich, dass ich sage, okay, es tut mir wahrscheinlich gut, wenn ich nicht allzu viel Zeit bei Instagram verbringe. Aber wenn ich daraus ein Gesetz ableite, wird es halt immer sehr schwierig, weil wir dann gleich in so eine Zensurfrage ja reinspringen. Also anders kommen wir da gar nicht umhin. Und deswegen war auch immer, als wir zu Influencern gefragt werden, was kann man machen, dann haben wir gesagt, die Influencer sollen sich löschen. Damit meinten wir einfach nicht, wir löschen die im Sinne von die Regierung, sollen das machen, sondern nein, eigentlich wäre gut, wenn Leute sich auch für andere Dinge interessieren, außer jetzt für Bibi und weiß ich nicht mehr.
Also wir haben jetzt in Amerika offenbar eine Wiederholung der deutschen Geschichte. Wir haben eine Zensursolar-Debatte. Wir haben ein Jonathan Hay, du hast jetzt Manfred Spitzer schon genannt. Wir haben Manfred Spitzers Buch zur Einsamkeit im Podcast gelesen und zwar sogar außerhalb des Salons, weil die Realität so drückte im Lockdown. Manfred Spitzers Buch Digitale Demenz ist sehr hart umstritten worden und kam auch in einer Zeit vor zehn Jahren oder so, als das CDF noch Login, irgendein Diskussionsformat erprobte, in dem dann Johnny Häusler gegen Manfred Spitzer und Twitter hat auch noch funktioniert. Also waren alle auf Johnny Häuslers Seite und an Manfred Spitzer in Grund und Boden argumentiert. Aber heute, nach Corona und mit allen Erfahrungen, jede Seite stimmt.
Aber was sagst du zu Studien, die es auch gibt, die sagen, dass in smartphone auch die Einsamkeit verringern kann? Und das ist vielleicht zum Beispiel für Leute aus der LGBT-Community, die 16 Jahre alt sind und die nicht in Frankfurt oder Berlin leben, doch eine ganz gute Möglichkeit ist, mit Menschen in Kontakt zu kommen, die ihresgleichen sind.
Ja, ich habe in der Alten Republik darüber geschrieben, dass wir, wenn wir das deutsche Schulsystem uns anschauen, dann unterbietet uns nur noch die Türkei im Ranking auf die Frage und das beantworten die Schüler dann selbst, empfindest du deine Schule als Safe Space? Dann sagen die Deutschen alle nein und wir denken immer noch, wir haben hier so ein tolles Bildungssystem.
Aber das liegt ja nicht nur im Smartphone, also du hast eben Mobbing angesprochen mit AI. Wenn ich dann denke, wie in unserer Schule gemobbt wurde, das war ja unglaublich.
Genau, genau.
Da hatte noch nicht mal jemand Nokia.
Ja, aber Wolfgang, wenn du in der Schule gemobbt wirst, ist die Antwort darauf nicht, zum Glück habe ich dann zu Hause in meinem Kinderzimmer ein Smartphone, wo ich das wieder ausgleichen kann, sondern da muss die Schule aufhören mit diesem Gemobbe.
Genau, aber da bin ich absolut dafür. Ich glaube, was hier gemacht wird und was bei Keir Starmer zu hören, weil der Keir Starmer sieht die sehr gute Serie Innocence, wir haben die auch sehr geliebt und sagt dann, ja jetzt müssen wir mal über Insel- und Smartphoneverbot usw. reden. Und das ist ja genau so, wie man es dann nicht machen müsste. Weil die Probleme ja viel tiefer sind. Warum werden eigentlich einzelne Personen gemobbt? Und zwar auch schon zu analogen Zeiten. Dass das dann nochmal andere Dimensionen annimmt. Ja, und ich glaube auch nicht, und stimme Taylor Lawrence zu, dass es ein Angriff auf die Plattform ist, sie sagt.
This bill and others like it are framed as cracking down on Big Tech. But it's not cracking down on Big Tech. It's cracking down on speech of users. Because Big Tech, as you said, they don't really care that much about free speech. The platforms are like fine, we'll go along with it, we'll censor it nationwide. We might as well, just to be compliant, like you said, and not jeopardize our business. And so there's not really any sort of advocacy group looking out for users in this situation.
Das stimmt alles. Und wir können heute sagen, Facebook ist das neue Fernsehen. Das ist eine Erfindung, die für die nächsten 50 Jahre bleibt, bis wirklich was Neues kommt. Aber das heißt noch lange nicht, dass wir uns nicht mal um diese Probleme, die da beschneiden, wie zum Beispiel, dass man zu Facebook überhaupt gar keine Alternative hat, egal was Facebook macht. Es ist in einem Jahr immer 100 Milliarden mehr wert als vorher. Weil der Markt etwas eht.
Ich bin absolut dafür.
Es gibt keine Alternative.
Wir brauchen ein besseres Internet. Da glaube ich, ist sie manchmal auch zu entschuldigend für das, was jetzt gerade ist im Internet. Nur sehe ich eben jetzt diese Maßnahmen, die getroffen werden, als äußerst kritisch. Und alle, die hier sind, sehen das auch so duinklusive, wenn du das hier hörst.
So the miners have to have the most restrictive settings enabled by default. Of course, Plattforms have no way of really knowing which user is the minor or not. Unless they do what? Age verification.
So, also ich sehe hier Taylor Lawrence und ihren Gesprächspartner Ich glaube, wir müssen jetzt schon der Plattform Logik unterworfen, weil Facebook sagt, ne Age Verification, das können wir ja nur so und so machen. Dann stellen die fest, das ist aber blöd, wir sind dagegen. Age Verification kann man auch ganz anders machen.
Aber wer bekommt da jetzt die Aufträge? Peter Thiel mit Palantir.
Genau. Ich weiß nach, als Not am Mann war und in Deutschland einfach gesagt wurde, wir müssen jetzt Kontakte verfolgen. Christian Drosten hat gesagt, dieses Virus brüdet erst mal fünf Tage, bevor man es sieht. Wir müssen also nachträglich Kontakt danach vollziehen. Wir schreiben jetzt in Restaurants alle auf, wer da war. Und dann alle ausgerastet völlig zurecht. Dann hat die Regierung gesagt, okay, wir haben eine Antwort. Wir haben einen zentralen Datenserver, auf dem locken sich alle ein und so weiter. Und dann kamen die ganzen Gruppen und haben gesagt, sorry, wenn ihr das macht, diese App nutzt niemand, weil euch niemand vertraut. Ihr müsst es dezentral machen.
Und dann kamen Leute wie Konstanze Kurz, die das ja dann auch erklärt hat, unter anderem, die haben was gemacht.
Und dann haben wir es dezentral bekommen.
Genau.
Das geht bei Age-Verification auch.
Ich habe keinen Zweifel daran. Nur, ich habe Zweifel daran, dass irgendjemand willens ist, das umzusetzen.
Und das ist das Problem.
Ja, wir sehen jetzt gerade eine autoritäre Wende. Und am liebsten hätten gerne alle Politiker mal die Namen der unliebsamen Leute. Weshalb ja auch Listen schon verschickt wurden von Akademikern und Künstlern, die man doch besser nicht mehr fördern sollte, weil man da mal gehört hat, dass die da und dort was geliked haben, was nicht der Staatsräson zum Thema Nordost entspricht. Und das sind ja alles solche Maßnahmen, die wir jetzt gerade sehen. Wäre das so dezentral, würde ich sagen, ja absolut bin ich dafür. Und ja, dass im Internet Kinder geschützt gehören, ist ja klar, weil sie das in der analogen Welt ja auch hören. Nur die Frage ist, fällt man so in einen Maulpanic? Also wollen wir mit dem was zu tun haben?
Jeder dritte junge Mann hatte noch nie eine Freundin. Du gehörst dazu, schau keine Pornos. Wähl nicht die Grünen.
Geh raus auf die frische Luft.
Steh zu dir. Sei selbstbewusst.
Guck geradeaus.
Und vor allem, lass dir nicht einreden, dass du lieb, soft, schwach und links zu sein hast.
Echte Männer sind rechts.
Echte Männer haben Ideale.
Echte Männer sind Patrioten.
Dann klappt es auch mit der Freundin.
Ja, dann klappt es auch mit der Freundin. Also wir nehmen aber hier vor allem mal mit, wir kennen ja diesen Clip, wir nehmen vor allem mal mit, schau keine Pornos. Und ich würde sagen, ja individuell tut die Pornografie auch vielen Menschen nicht gut. The question is, brauche ich jetzt ein Gesetz, um Pornografie einzuschränken? Und damit kommen wir zu Lil Tay zurück.
18-year-old social media star, Lil Tay, made over $1 million by launching an OnlyFans account shortly after her 18th birthday. Even though she apparently only posted safer work content to her page, the launch generated a massive backlash online. People on the left and the right are now calling for OnlyFans to be banned and for the criminalization of porn.
Ganz erstaunlich. Also, jetzt macht man aus diesem einen Fall plötzlich ein Exempel und sagt, wir gehen dann noch weiter.
It's because of the backlash that it generated. And that backlash is coming right as the United Kingdom rolled out these horrible age verification laws that were really predicated on cracking down on adult content and porn content. We're just overwhelmingly seeing this moral panic about porn and OnlyFans, et cetera, used to strip our civil liberties on the Internet.
Ja, also, das ist eigentlich technisch ein gelöstes Problem. Wir müssten nur einfach sagen, okay, das ist Online-Content. Wir machen eine ganz kleine Bezahlschranke hin. Denn in Deutschland ist ja so der RMV, der hier in Frankfurt Fahrkarten verkauft. Du kannst im Automaten gehen mit Bargeld bezahlen. Aber jedes Mal, wenn meine Töchter fahren wollen, müssen sie mir eine Nachricht schicken, damit ich in meiner App, weil ich nämlich der einzige bin, der einen Zahlungsdienstleister haben darf auf seinem Handy, die haben ja minderjährige Handyaccounts, dann mache ich einen Screenshot von dem Ticket und schicke denen das zurück. Meine Kids sind also ausgeschlossen davon, Online-Käufe zu machen, außer in manchen Fällen. Wahrscheinlich müsste ich das dann nochmal bestätigen.
Ich sage das mal gerade, jede Podcast-Aufnahme muss einmal unterbrochen werden.
Ich habe sogar schon auf der Bühne hier Fahrkarten gekauft.
Weil Stefan gerade ein Fahrticket kaufen muss, weil das sonst nicht geht.
So, und damit kriegt man dieses Problem aber gelöst.
Die Sache ist ja, bei OnlyFans ist es jetzt zu bezahlen. Also ich glaube nicht, dass ein 15-Jähriger sich einen OnlyFans-Account verschaffen kann, um dort was zu ko... Also sowieso hochladen nichts, aber um dort was zu konsumieren. Das wird nur möglich sein, wenn man die Eltern überredet, die Kreditkarte rauszurücken und zu sagen, ich mache da irgendwas.
Und Kreditkarte meine ich ja gerade nicht, weil jeder kann sich eine Kreditkarte holen und die Zahlen abschreiben und so weiter. Also Onlyfans, wenn es mit Kreditkarte geht, geht das. Aber wenn man jetzt, und das ist dann die Frage des Vertrautes, sagt, okay, wir haben Zahlungsdienstleister wie Apple oder Google, die eben Apple Pay, Google Pay, Garmin Pay und so weiter. Die geben ja an den Händler wirklich nur eine Zufallszahl weiter. Also man kann dort, und dem kann man auch vertrauen, anonym bezahlen, als würde man Bargeld benutzen. Man muss es nur machen.
Und will man es? Sie sagt ja...
This Democrat DNC meme account quote posted the news about Lil Tay and said, I'm pretty liberal about what I think the rules of Internet sex work should be, but there should be laws about child influencers and porn. Again, she is not a child influencer. She is an adult.
Ja. Also es wird jetzt plötzlich OnlyFans als Plattform grundsätzlich in Frage gestellt. Und jetzt kann man OnlyFans blöd finden oder so, aber will man wirklich eine Zensur haben? Und wo greift sie dann als Nächstes? Vielleicht gehen wir mal einen Clip weiter. Ey, geh los.
I mean, I went to college in Colorado and there were multiple girls I knew that were working at strip clubs at the age of 18 in order to pay their bills.
Ja, also das ist die Realität. 18-Jährige können in Strip Clubs arbeiten. Man könnte übrigens sagen, sie können sich auch bei Militär melden und irgendwo an der Front sterben. Aber sie sollen jetzt bitte nicht zu OnlyFans gehen. Also was ist das für eine komische Debatte?
Porn. Obviously, we're seeing it happen right now in the UK and in the US, where it's being used to strip our civil liberties, right? Like this is the reason why the UK rolled out age verification, which is all about tying your offline identity to your online behavior. You now have to scan your face to use Spotify and YouTube and all of these platforms. We're seeing mass censorship, you know, where you're seeing basically entire subreddits about abortion, reproductive justice, R slash periods is censored in the UK. And actually all of the information about sexual abuse and child exploitation is also censored. So if you are a young person being abused because of these age verification laws, you now can't even find basic information to get help. You can't even contextualize or understand your abuse because you can't access that quote unquote adult material.
Das ist diese Absurdität, das jetzt plötzlich alles als harmful gilt. Bedeutet also, auch die Seiten, auf denen man sich informieren kann, über sexuellen Missbrauch, wie kann ich dagegen vorgehen, was kann ich tun. Sind dann plötzlich auch nicht mehr zugänglich, weil man so alles in einem Abwasch sagt, können wir jetzt erledigen.
Also hier finde ich auch, das ist ein ernsthaftes Problem, denn hier werden gesetzliche Initiativen, die aufgrund eines moralischen Einschlags in der Gesellschaft entstehen, einfach missbraucht von Politikern, die Probleme lösen wollen, die es vorher gar nicht gab. Wie zum Beispiel, sie ist zwar 18, aber ich möchte ihr trotzdem noch den Umgang mit dem eigenen Körper reglementieren oder wie auch immer. Ich habe mit Christoph Engelmann, der vor Jahren mal beim CCC so einen Vortrag hielt, über die Identifikationssysteme, die die Regierung schon immer wollte in Amerika. Also seit es Telefone gibt, hatte man immer so eine Idee, wir bauen da von der Regierung so ein extra kleines Gerät ein und dann weiß man, wer anruft und so. Das haben wir ja bis heute noch nicht. Also irgendwelche Nummern rufen einfach an und mittlerweile ist ja Apple und Google so weit, dass sie zumindest eine Vermutung anstellen, wer da gerade anruft, wenn die Nummer nicht im Telefobo steht. So, und das finde ich auch erstaunlich, dass wir eigentlich immer schon gesagt haben, die digitale Welt ist gar nicht so eine eigene Welt. Neuland, wir haben uns vor 15 Jahren schon alle drüber lustig gemacht über so eine politische Semantik. Und dass wir es bis heute noch nicht geschafft haben, obwohl wir mittlerweile Identifikationssysteme haben, sie ernsthaft zu benutzen. Denn so wie sie eben sagte, man muss jetzt sein Gesicht scannen, um was hat sie gesagt, Snapchat zu benutzen oder so. Also wenn ich auf meinem Handy einstelle, dass Snapchat als App auf meinem Telefon verborgen ist, bis ich mich identifiziere, dann scannt ja nicht Snapchat, sondern Apple scannt. Ich vertraue Apple und die vertrauen Apple. Und damit wird aber Apple eine wirklich neue Instanz, die quasi hoheitliche Aufgaben unternimmt.
Ja, und wollen wir das?
Ich sage jetzt mal ganz mutig, ja, ich will das.
Kat Tenbark ist dort im Interview. Sie weist die folgende Szene.
And this is all happening, of course, against this backdrop of things like the Kids Online Safety Act. There are 11 states so far in America that have passed some version of age verification legislation, and of course, Project 2025, which wants to strip all women of our civil liberties and rights. Yes. And it really blows my mind that you will have these exact same people talk about Project 2025, and you have to question whether they have any idea what they're talking about because I have not read Project 2025 in its entirety. I know it's like a thousand pages long, but I have searched for all of the sections that have to do with porn. I've searched for all the sections that have to do with trans people and with women's rights, and it takes you like 10 minutes to read through, and it is spelled out very, very clearly and explicitly that their plan that is in action, that is already happening, and has already had massive consequences, is to take porn, criminalize porn.
Ja, das ist Maximilian Krah. Das ist genau diese Logik. Die Frauen sollen bitte nicht mit ihrem Körper das machen. Und zugleich aber gibt es so eine Fetischisierung der jungen Frauen. Die sollen bitte möglich mit 19 schon beginnen, Kinder zu bekommen. Und dann wird das noch genetisch und so weiter begründet, dass die Situation der sich befindet. Und ich bin echt verblüfft darüber, dass wir zum einen sagen, Trump ist so schlimm. Und dann haben wir die ganze Zeit eine Zusammenarbeit von Republikanern und Demokraten bei so einer Sache. Und ich sehe schon, dass das auch eine Folie wird hier für Europa oder so. Dass man plötzlich dann mit Meloni und Orban und irgendwie in der CDU-Regierung zusammen versucht, die jungen Leute zu schützen. Und dann heißt es auch vor Antisemitismus und Transideologie. Und dann wissen wir, was da noch alles dann darunter fällt.
Ich will mal eine ganz scharfe These, auch gegen mich selbst. Ich peinige mich jetzt ein bisschen selbst. Wenn ich dies Jahr fahre, bin ich das zehnte Mal auf einem Cars Communication-Kongress, obwohl ich mich gar nicht so als Hacker fühle, einfach nur weil ich denke, da sind irgendwie coole Leute. Das heißt, ich habe ganz schön viele Vorträge gehört zu diesem Thema und habe vor über zehn Jahren bei Schirmacher diese digitale Debatte mitgeführt. Wir sind zum Bundesinnenministerium gefahren, haben darum recherchiert, warum die das so lax handhaben mit der DSGVU und so weiter und so fort. Und mittlerweile denke ich, die Amerikaner hatten ihre Chance, zusammen mit Obama, zusammen mit Joe Biden, aus aktivistischer Sicht wie Taylor Lorenz, ein Age-Verification-System zu bauen, bei dem man mal nicht sagt, es ist eine Idee der Regierung, ich finde sie scheiße. Denn wir sind jetzt an diesem Punkt, wo wir in Deutschland immer waren, irgendwann wird die AfD regieren und was machen wir dann? Because age verification will come. Nur jetzt macht es halt dann JD Vans.
Genau.
Das ist ein ernsthaftes Podcast.
Und die Frage ist, wer es dann hier macht und wie. Und wir wissen ja, wie sehr Palantir hier schon verbreitet ist, selbst in einem grün regierten Land wie Baden-Württemberg. Und wir können uns jetzt schon mal ein abschreckendes Beispiel zum Schluss ansehen, die letzten drei Clips. Und zwar Mario Punkt. Der war bei WeltTV zu Gast bei dem Format Politiker grillen. Und während er so die Würstchen auflegt, wird er befragt zum Thema Smartphones, Social Media und junge Menschen. Also Ministerpräsident von Thüringen.
Ja, wo ist der da? Das ist doch nicht Thüringen. Gibt es da so hohe Häuser?
Nein, die sind natürlich auf dem Dach vom Springer Verlag.
Ach so, in Berlin, okay.
Wo wir gerade bei den Kindern sind, Sie haben vorhin auf dem Weg hierher an den Grill erzählt, dass sie die Handys aus den Schulen verbannen wollen. Wie soll das gehen? Wollen wir mal probieren langsam?
Ja, wir fangen mal mit der hier an. Die ist in jedem Fall so weit.
Man lässt sich jetzt mal erst ein Milchchen Zeit.
Wir haben das eigentlich on time hier. Die ist ein bisschen brauner, je nachdem, wie sie wollen. Ja, hm. Ich sag gleich was dazu, eine Sekunde. Sie müssen auf die Currywurst da.
Ansonsten, die sind auch ganz okay.
Mach ich jetzt auch immer so komplizierte Fragen.
Ein Würstchen grillen, ja.
Ich lieg die mal hier oben auf.
Der Würstchen kann das sehr gut.
Das ist doch ein bisschen wie Knusper, Knusper, Knäuschen. Jetzt wo wir bei den Kindern sind. Ich guck mal, ob es schon dick genug ist und so.
Ich nehm immer noch ein Würstchen.
Ja, ist doch hier welche Geschichte?
Ja. 11 und 13. Wenn ich sehe, die waren die Letzten in ihrer Klasse, die in Händen liegen.
Moment, Moment, Moment. Hier waren wir.
Wo wir gerade bei den Kindern sind. Körri, du wirst da direkt auf die Wurst ballern?
Ich mach das schon. Ich mache mir große Sorgen in der Frage, wie unsere Kinder eigentlich in der Digitalisierung alleingelassen werden. Und das beschäftigt mich auch als zweifache Familienvater. Ich habe zwei Söhne.
So, also wer lässt die Kinder in der Digitalisierung alleine? Die Eltern sind es nicht.
Aber vielleicht die Schule? Ja, wir und weiter.
11 und 13. Wenn ich sehe, die waren die Letzten in ihrer Klasse, die ein Handy bekommen haben. Wenn ich mir anschaue, wie Jugendliche, wie Kinder damit umgehen, dann besorgt mich das sehr, weil sie im Prinzip alleingelassen werden von uns. Und wir so tun, als ob das alles kein Problem ist. Aber wenn wir uns überlegen, Kinder werden auf Social-Media-Kanälen losgelassen, wo Fremde auf sie zugehen können, wo sie im Prinzip Enthauptungen, wo sie Pornos, wo sie Dinge sehen können, mit denen sie quasi kindlich gar nicht umgehen können. Das verändert ihren Gemütszustand. Das verändert auch ihr Bewusstsein. Und deswegen glaube ich, es ist wichtig, dass wir uns als Deutschland auf die Initiative einstellen, dass kein Social Media vor 16 Jahren gegeben wird. Wir werden in Thüringen handy-freie Schulen für die Kinder im Grundschulbereich in jedem Fall. Und dann mit Experten, werden wir jetzt auch noch darüber hinaus diskutieren. Wir wollen auch auf die Frage eine Antwort finden, wie kann man eigentlich achtsam miteinander umgehen, weil zutage auch viele Eltern leisten sich so eine Art Helikopterdasein und geben keine Freiräume mehr. Und das alles zusammen mit Schleppich.
Wie soll das konkret gehen?
Wir werden einen rechtlichen Vorschlag machen, dass in Thüringen die Grundschulen, dass dort keine Smartphones mehr beziehungsweise in der Unterrichtszeit eingesetzt werden können. Klar ist, wenn die Kinder nach der Schule informieren wollen, dass sie abgeholt werden oder dass sie jetzt auf dem Schulweg sind, dann muss man das ermöglichen. Aber nicht in der Schulzeit. Weil was passiert denn da? Wenn die sich als sie oder ich in die Schule gegangen sind, konnten wir damals den Fernseher mit in die Schule bringen. Konnten wir damals mit das Shopping verhalten. Oder eben auch die Suchdatenbank. Nein, das ging ja alles nicht.
Die Suchdatenbank. Und wir hatten ja noch den Rechenschieber. Wir hatten auch keinen Taschenrechner. Also ich kann ja verstehen, dass man jetzt sagt, die Handys müssen nicht jederzeit präsent sein in der Schule und in der Grundschule vielleicht sowieso nicht. Und man kann da ja darüber nachdenken. Also ich bin ja durchaus auch willenskonstruktiv zu sein. Nur was da hier alles so miteinander vermischt, also von Pornos im Internet, zu denen Jugendliche Zugang haben, das gucken sie ja vermutlich doch nicht, wenn sie Mathematikunterricht mal das Smartphone rausholen.
Ohne Freistunde wäre schon viel geholfen.
Genau. Und dazu müsste es ein paar Lehrer geben, die dann da sind. Also diese ganzen Geschichten hier so alle mal zusammengezählt werden. Und das wird zurückgeführt auf Smartphone und Social Media. Und zu sagen, na ja, erst ab 16 Jahren dann. Ich weiß nicht, also was 16-Jährigen sonst schon alles zugemutet wird, nämlich viele von denen sind schon in der Ausbildung. Aber sie sollen dann nicht auf Social Media sein. Das ist doch merkwürdig, beseigeneartig. Und dann sollen sie ja in anderthalb Jahren schon fürs Militär bereitstehen. Wir hören noch mal weiter.
Also insofern glaube ich, da achtsamer miteinander umzugehen und auch zuversichtliche Kinder wieder zu produzieren und nicht so Angst zu verbreiten oder letztlich in sich eine Sache vor Augen führen. Und die, finde ich, sagt eigentlich alles. Es gibt eine neue Studie, die belegt, dass Kinder zwischen 10 und 17 Jahren, fast jedes vierte Kind, ist mittlerweile angstbefangen. Also ich brauche noch Senf in der Thüringen.
Ich dachte, die Profis machen ohne.
Das ist ein wichtiges Thema, dass Angst bei Kindern.
Geht auch tatsächlich ohne.
Wenn man überlegt, dass jedes vierte Kind im Prinzip mittlerweile angstbefangen ist, durch die Social-Media-Nutzung, dann ist das doch ein klares Wandsignal. Mittlerweile scrollt jeder Jugendliche pro Tag 200 Meter mit seinem Daumen auf seinem Handy herum. Also die bewegen sich nicht 50 Meter, aber 200 Meter auf dem Handy schaffen sie. Und das alles zusammengebrannt sind, glaube ich, Dinge, da dürfen wir nicht teilnahmslos an der Seitenlinie stehen. Da muss Politik jetzt auch auf die neuen Entwicklungen achten. Das heißt nicht, Digitalisierung nicht zu ermöglichen. Im Gegenteil, die Chancen von künstlicher Intelligenz und von vielen anderen Dingen, wie sollten wir nutzen als Deutschland. Aber wir sollten schon achtzehnmal damit umgehen. Und schauen Sie da an, Kinder, die virtuelle und die reale Welt verschwimmen miteinander. Und mittlerweile, dritte Stichwunden und so weiter. Alles bei Kindern und Jugendlichen. Das hat doch Konsequenzen und kommt meiner Meinung nach genau aus diesem Bereich.
Dritte Stichwunden, weiß ich nicht, hat alles irgendwie mit dem Smartphone zu tun. Und jedes vierte Kind hat Angst. Da habe ich nochmal gesagt, Moment, jedes vierte Kind, da war noch mal irgendwas anders. Jedes vierte Kind und Jugendliche. Ja genau, jedes vierte Kind und jeder vierte Jugendliche wächst in Deutschland in Armut auf. Beziehungsweise ist, um das korrekt auszudrücken, armutsgefährdet. Könnte auch Angst verursachen, würde ich sagen. Liegt vielleicht nicht nur an Instagram.
Ein Hoch auf Thüringen.
Also wir sind gewarnt, Freespeech das große neue Thema.
Ja, damit haben wir den ernsten Teil abgeschlossen. Wir machen jetzt eine kleine Pause. Vor der Pause ein Kleinklip. Ihr dürft jetzt alle für euch rätseln. Seid ihr schon erwachsen genug? Oder steckt euch noch ein bisschen Kind? Jugendlich oder was auch immer? Wir sehen jetzt Susanne Daubner, die eine Fernsehsendung ankündigt, die ich gar nicht kannte. Ich wollte eigentlich nur Sommerinterviews gucken und bin offenbar falsch abgebogen. Wie auch immer, könnte ein Rabbit Hole sein. Also jeder für euch macht sich jetzt Gedanken, ist das, was ich hier gerade sehe, cringe oder ist das voll cool?
Hey, was geht, ihr coolen Kids? Schön, dass ihr wieder den Stream angedreht habt, denn Tagesschau Together is back. Heute schauen wir gemeinsam das ARD-Sommerinterview mit Deutschland-CEO Friedrich Merz. Wir wollen wissen, wie der Bundeskanzler die Lage der Nation einschätzt. Rambo-Zambo oder Flaute? Wir gehen rein.
Also Rambo-Zambo oder Flaute, ihr dürft jetzt drüber nachdenken. 20 Minuten und dann frage ich euch ab.
Schöne Pause, bis gleich. So langsam geht es weiter. Die letzten eingetrodet sind, vielleicht hat Mick schon mal eine Frage für uns.
Hast du inzwischen Breaking Bad gesehen?
Ob ich inzwischen Breaking Bad gesehen habe? Ja, die erste Staffel, aber das war dann auch für mich auserzählt. Okay, es tut mir leid.
Dann die nächste einfache Frage.
Was macht dir Hoffnung in diesen schwierigen Zeiten?
Was macht mir Hoffnung in diesen schwierigen Zeiten? Steffen, was macht dir Hoffnung? Das sind aber auch immer so Fragen. Man will immer gleich jetzt so eine...
Keine Ahnung. Mir fällt nichts.
Man glaubt gleich, in so einen Habeck-Ton verfallen zu müssen, oder? Ja. Ich denke, wenn wir gemeinsam noch mal erkennen, dass wir vielleicht auch da kooperativer herangehen könnten.
Ich habe heute meinen Günther-Krass-Kort-Anzug an. Mir sollte also irgendwas auf Hoffnung und so einfallen, aber ich nicht.
Also Hoffnung ist eigentlich nicht so mein Modus. Das ist wirklich nicht das, an was ich so denke. Also das ist einfach nicht so meine Sache. Also ich kann natürlich im Kleinen hoffen auf manches, aber ich habe jetzt nicht so im Ganzen große Hoffnung. Das überlasse ich dem Kirchentag.
So, dahinten stehen nur noch drei Leute und wollen eine Cola kaufen.
Mick, hast du noch eine Frage, bevor wir anfangen?
Lass uns mal rückblickend in unser wichtigstes Salonbuch.
Ah, das ist interessant. Was war rückblickend in unser wichtigstes Salonbuch?
Also das erste war nicht schlecht, das erste gemeinsame Bullshit Jobs. Ja, die These von Anfänge, dass unsere Kolonialisierung oder unsere Modernität eigentlich Kolonialisierungs-Importe waren, fand ich auch sehr stark. Also zweimal David Graeber auf jeden Fall.
Ja, was soll das sein?
Bei mir würde ich schon sagen, war es einmal The Technological Republic, also noch gar nicht lange her. Also als wichtiges Buch, nicht im Sinne von das ist ein tolles Buch, sondern wir. Ich bin doch sehr froh, dass wir das gelesen haben. History has begun. Es ist, glaube ich, auch nochmal interessant zu sehen jetzt, wo er dieses Show, der Show, der Show nochmal mit Trump sich dann realisiert hat. Und wahrscheinlich noch, ja, also eigentlich eine produktive Diskussion war eigentlich die vierte Gewalt von Wälzer und Precht, fand ich als Diskussion einfach zwischen uns sehr gut.
Ja, und wir kriegen bald wieder Trecht.
Im Oktober, Übereinungsfeiert, Free Speech, da sind wir ja wieder.
Vielleicht noch, wegen dieser Eintese, jedes Grad mehr macht eine Milliarde mehr Klimaflüchtlinge.
Ja, ja, also eigentlich sind das so, also Graeber und auch M sind eigentlich ja diese Bücher, die wirklich so die Perspektive so im Ganzen verschieben. Also jetzt nicht so, ach, wo könnte man da reformieren, sondern wir müssen uns wirklich neu denken. Und das fand ich da sehr gut. Und ja, das sind eigentlich auch die Bücher, auf die man immer wieder so zurückkommt, auch wenn man sie nicht laufend zitiert, aber die einen doch gedanklich dann beschäftigen.
So, die letzten kommen rein. Wir machen das jetzt wie im Bundestag. Niemand wartet mehr auf Ruhe. Man fängt einfach an. Ihr sitzt hier sowieso wie drei Fraktionen. Unvereinbar rechts, links, Mitte. Hast du diesen Clip gesehen von Daniela? Ja, Instagram, Junge, Frau. Kapsenberger? Nee, nee, nee. Es war, fällt mir gott nach, spontan ein sehr lustiger Move, weil jemand auf Twitter geschrieben hat, Achtung, Achtung Leute, die Linken sind gar nicht Mitte.
Ach so, ja.
Und da gab's die Deutsch-Aufklärung. Nee, links heißt sie auch, links und nicht Mitte.
Ja.
Wie heißt sie denn? Daniela? Du weißt, ich hab ihr Buch zu Hause. Ihr poetisches. Egal, wir kommen jetzt demnächst auf die Linke zu sprechen. Denn wir gucken ja jetzt eine neue Sendung. Wir haben eben schon Susanne Daubner zum ersten Gehirrt. Gehirrt? Gehirrt? Wir hören jetzt Ingo Zamparoni. Wir wissen von ihm, besonders cool ist er nicht. Deswegen gelingt es ihm nicht so.
Hey, Ingo Zamparoni. Du willst wissen, wie viel dein Auto wert ist?
Nö.
Ah, ah gut. Aber ist auch eh nicht mehr ein Fachgebiet. Von daher, welcome back bei Tagesschau together.
Hab ich nicht verstanden.
Das ist die Parodie. Du weißt gar nicht, welche Werbung gemeint ist, oder?
Nee.
Ach das ist interessant.
Werbung? Ich gucke ja ARD.
Er kennt nur Abuvo nicht und weiß nicht welche Werbung. Mein Lieber. Und ich kann aber erklären, warum das so ist. Ich kann erklären, warum das so ist. Stefan bezahlt ja dafür, keine Werbung sehen zu müssen und sieht deshalb nie Werbung bei YouTube. Ich hab noch einen Browser, auf dem ich Werbung sehe und es gibt eine Werbung, die sehr penetrant ist. Und selbst wenn du keinen Führerschein hast, wirst du die angezeigt bekommen. Und zwar taucht in dieser Werbung, also man sieht jemanden, der zu seinem Auto geht oder so und dann taucht dort jemand auf und dieser Mensch guckt ihn an und sagt Ralf Schumacher. Und dann steht Ralf Schumacher da und erklärt, wie man seinen Gebrauchtwagen im Internet verkaufen kann. Und das ist so ein Meme geworden, beziehungsweise so ein viraler Hit. Und ich glaube wirklich aus Versehen. Denn die Überlegung war, wie folgt, diese Internetseite, auf der man Autos verkaufen kann, hatte sich gedacht, wir brauchen einen Promi. Es war aber nicht so viel Geld da, um so einen ganz richtigen Promi zu bekommen. Also hat man Ralf Schumacher genommen. Jetzt hat man sich gedacht, den kennen ja manche vielleicht so vom Sehen nicht direkt. Also muss unbedingt gesagt werden Ralf Schumacher. Denn niemand guckt ja in den Espresso-Werbung und da sagt jemand, ach, George Clooney. Jeder weiß, wer George Clooney ist. Und durch diese eher verkrampfte Art der Einführung der Person hat sich aber dann so ein Meme entwickelt und deswegen jetzt diese Reaktion. Also wenn ich das nächste Mal auf dich zukomme, sage, Stefan Schulz, dann ist das eine Parodie.
Okay. Okay, ich hab das zuerst andersrum gehört, nämlich da sagt, du willst wissen, was mein Autowert ist. Es gibt nämlich von Jens Riva ein sehr berühmtes TikTok-Video, wie er oben am Fenster steht. Und sich drüber lustig macht. Wie Ingo Zamparoni unten einparkt. Und da ist das Internet drauf gekommen, dass er irgendein Mercedes Coupe fährt. Und wollte dann die ganze Zeit wissen, was sein Auto wert ist. Aber, ja, okay. Aber das Wichtigste ist schon mal geklebt.
Da muss man schon ganz schön tief im Tagesschau-Rabbit Hole sein.
Er, ich und mit. Dienstag wieder. Wir geben Susanne Daugner noch eine Chance.
Heute ist Sonntag. Checkt ihr? Ja, Tatort zahlt, aber vorher Tagesschau together. Wir starten wieder eine Watchparty. Diesmal zum ARD-Sommerinterview mit Felix Banaschak von den Grünen. Und wir haben natürlich noch ein weiteres Thema. Gönnt euch also auf Loki-Basis diesen Stream mit Hanin und Felix.
So, seit ich diesen Clip kenne, frage ich jeden, was Loki genau bedeutet. Da ihr nicht alle gleichzeitig anwerten könnt, ihr könnt es einfach vorspielen. Gönnt euch mal bitte die folgenden Clips in Loki-Basis. Wie würde das aussehen? Jeder nimmt jetzt diese Zeitung ein. Ne, neue Reaktion.
Was muss man da machen?
Ich weiß auch nicht, Loki halt. Also Loki ein bisschen.
So irgendwie so ein bisschen Durchhänger oder so?
Ja, jedenfalls. Wir haben jetzt drei solche Anmoderationen gehört. Wir wissen, das Sommerinterview ist der Sommersendeplatz für den Bericht aus Berlin. Da hat man also eine halbe Stunde, in der sitzt man auf Terrassen und lässt sich bescheiden vom Adenauer Express, oder wie es heißt, mit Buswärme teilweise schon gesehen. Das allerdings sind Sendungen, die gehen drei Stunden, zweieinhalb bis drei Stunden, und die kommen auch nicht im Fernsehen. Die kommen im Stream bei Twitch. Da hab ich mich natürlich erinnert an 2019. Ich wollte den Gedanken schon abgeschrieben haben. Es passiert ja doch nichts und so. Aber hier seht ihr jetzt gleich nochmal einen ganz seriösen Stefan Schulz in der Bundespressekonferenz. Ich finde, man sollte jetzt aufhören mit diesem Gelächel über das, was bei YouTube erfolgreich ist, und sich diese Formate, die Medien, die Ansprache und alle neuen Prinzipien mal richtig angucken und das auch mit wissenschaftlicher Unterstützung auszubeuten versuchen, so dass man danach, wenn man die Prinzipien durchschaut hat, versuchen kann und dann wieder praktische Intelligenz braucht man dann in einem Versuch nach dem anderen, da die Inhalte, die man gerne, aus welchen Erwägungen auch immer, da kann man dann die ganz alten demokratietheoretischen Überlegungen, warum brauchen wir Medien, wieder aktivieren und sagen, dann machen wir es jetzt so. Aber weder die Tagesschau noch die Tagesthemen noch Deutschlandfunk, der Tagendepodcast, hat sich irgendwie beeindrucken lassen von diesen Rezo-Videos. Funktioniert, also die Formatstarre ist fast beängstigend, wenn man sich Sorgen um die Demokratie macht.
Es wird sicher interessant, wenn wir in einem Jahr noch mal drüber sprechen, was dann Journalisten vielleicht und Medien damit weitergemacht haben. Ich danke euch sehr für dieses Panel.
Ein Jahr später wurde da natürlich nicht drüber gesprochen, weil Corona.
Aber du hast jetzt im Prinzip die Büchse der Pantera da geöffnet.
Ja, ich habe eben gesagt, wenn ihr euch nicht wandelt, wird die Demokratie abgeschafft. Und jetzt haben wir Trump. Und die Demokratie ist abgeschafft. Und übrig bleibt, die Tagesschau bei Twitch. Genau, dass sie jetzt noch mal was Neues probieren. Wir gucken uns jetzt an, was sie hier Neues probiert haben. Also wir lernen jetzt erst mal die Streamer kennen.
Danke Susanne.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück bei Tagesschau together. Ich bin Felix.
Mein Name ist Hanin. Hallo.
Hallo. Ganz unschuldig zu Beginn natürlich. Jetzt fragt man sich so ein bisschen, wenn die Tagesschau mit Together ein Stream machen. Hier, 100.000 Euro Personalbudget pro Monat würde ich sagen. Das sind 15 Leute. Man fragt sich, ist es eine Kamera? Zwei Mikrofone. Wofür bräuchten wir noch? Ja gut, wer mit Smink, der aus den Fragen sortiert. Warum stehen da 13 Leute im Bild? Es ist ein bisschen unklar, aber gut. Sie begrüßen den Chat. Es gibt noch ein Chat.
Aber erstmal Chat an euch. Die Frage, wie geht's euch? Was läuft so? Wie seid ihr so drauf?
Harrybo307, kann ich auch ein Fax schicken? Ja, das Faxgerät ist hier unten.
Genau, kommt gleich raus.
Kommt gleich raus bei uns.
Harrybo567 macht ein Joke.
Hat diese Frage gestellt.
Es könnte sein, dass überhaupt nur Harrybo567 in diesem Chat ist.
Harrybo307 schreibt, komme ich jetzt ins Fernsehen? Also im Zweifel, wir sind ja bei Tagesschau24, später auch.
Ja, später kommst du ins Fernsehen. Wären du ein Kommentar schreibst oder mehrere?
Theoretisch, wenn du ein Kommentar schreibst oder mehrere. Nicht zu viel Spam.
Genau.
Das mit dem Fax war ja eine Referenz an Viva. Du erinnerst dich, da gab es die Sendung Interaktiv mit den Leuten, die man heute auch noch kennt, eher aus dem Dschungelcamp oder Adebisi oder so. Und die haben dann auch Fax entgegen genommen.
Ja. Und darf ich jetzt ins Fernsehen? Ist natürlich Stefan Raab irgendwas?
Nein, das ist, soweit ich weiß, Ingolf Lück für diese Sat1-Show.
Oder Jochen Wittwethos, nein?
Nicht. Ingolf Lück, komm ich jetzt ins Fernsehen oder so. Ich glaube, das ist Ingolf Lück.
Wolltest du aufklären?
Doch, es gibt bestätigte, Prisco Schneider war Sebastian Pastewka. Es war wieder was anderes.
Na, wie auch immer. Also offenbar gibt's in dieser Sendung, die sich am Anfang schlitten, hallo, Chad.
Bedeutet aber, Habibow ist schon ein bisschen älter. Eigentlich aus dem Twitch-Alter raus, wenn der noch Ingolf Lück und all das beratert.
Ich weiß gar nicht, ob das Habibow, Habibow, aber es ist jedenfalls, der selber hat jetzt den Joke gemacht, also offenbar schaut nur einer zu. Nein, es schaut nicht nur einer zu, denn ihr seht ja hinter denen, da ist ja so was.
Genau, wir freuen uns, dass Sie wieder da sind und dass ihr wieder da seid. Und ihr könnt euch auch richtig, richtig krass beteiligen hier in diesem Stream. Und zwar geht das mit unseren Extensions. Und zwar macht ihr das ja auch schon fleißig. Ihr könnt euch customisern. Und dann taucht ihr hinter uns auf als Avatar. Und ja, einige machen das auch schon. Den sehen wir hier gerade. Noah 18. Noah 18 ist auch mit dabei.
Mit der Cap. Sehr cool. Jeder von euch hat so seinen eigenen Style.
Genau.
Ja, also sechs Jahre, nachdem Stefan Schulz in der Bundespreisekonferenz fragte, wo sind denn die neuen Formate mit denselben Inhalten, haben wir jetzt gar keine Inhalte mehr. Und absurde Scheißformat. Und wir haben eine neue Sprache. Nicht nur das. Nicht nur eine neue Sprache. Die alte Sprache wird auch aussortiert. Aber ganz gut gemeint.
Okay, ja, liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer, es geht gleich los mit dem ARD Sommerinterview. Was ist denn, Felix?
Ich feier das, wie du das so sagst, liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer. Ich feier das, liebe Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer. Als wäre das Fernsehen schon am Start, dachte ich gerade.
Ich bin ein bisschen oldschool mitgebracht.
Hat es euch angesprochen gefühlt, Chat.
Chat, Zuschauerinnen und Zuschauer. Im Prinzip ist der Vibe so, wie auch immer ihr adressiert werden möchte. Aber das war, glaube ich, wahrscheinlich auch so Reflex. Userinnen und User, Nutzerinnen und Nutzer.
Ich denke ja auch immer, ganz große Fragen werden.
Wie viel Zynismus muss man mitbringen, um eine solche Sendung zu konzipieren? Denn das ist ja eine Sendung, die richtet sich an junge Menschen, aber ja auch nicht an kleinen Kinder, die die Teletubbies gucken. Or so und mit 16, 17 ist man ja zum Beispiel normal ansprechbar. Also ist meine Erfahrung jedenfalls.
Ja, stimmt, du hast recht. Es ist ja ein bisschen unklar. Ich würde jetzt sagen, grob gerundet, die Sendung ist jetzt schon 30 Minuten alt. Es kam bisher nicht herum. Jetzt versucht man so langsam ins innertliche einzusteigen. Sie zeigen uns, weil sie sehr viel Zeit zu füllen haben, wie aufwendig es ist, eine Person im Interview Fragen zu stellen. Wir sehen das hier. Eine weitere Journalistin ist am Set des Sommerinterviews und zeigt uns, wo Friedrich Merz gleich interviewt wird. Und die Kamera schwenkt so ein bisschen rum. Wir sehen, wie viele Leute da so abhängen.
Ja, und ihr seht, hier ist einiges los. Wir gehen mal wieder aus dem Set raus. Und ja, ich hoffe, die Eindrücke kommen bei euch gut rüber.
Die kommen auf jeden Fall an, ja.
Sehr spannend. So, es war ja auch eine Zeitlang nicht sicher, ob ihr das Ganze dann innen machen müsstet, wegen des Wetters. Und jetzt seid ihr wieder draußen. Entsprechend des Titels des Sommerinterviews. Und kannst du uns vielleicht einmal noch erklären, wie denn die Vorbereitungen vorher waren? Das ist ja auch enorm aufwendig, wie man gerade aussieht, ne?
Ja, ihr könnt euch vorstellen, dass so ein Bundeskanzler nicht einfach so vorbeispaziert kommt.
Ihr seht hier links oben, das ist das Bundeskanzleramt. Das ist Paul Löberhaus, aber er ahnt dir, wie nah das Bundeskanzleramt ist. Warum kommt er nicht einfach vorbeispaziert? Das wäre die journalistische Frage. Warum ist das so aufwendig? Was findet da statt? Und außerdem, wir haben gerade im Schwenk gesehen, Markus Preiß ist schon im Gespräch mit Friedrich Merz. Wir kennen alle den Spruch, den Klaus Kleber immer wieder gemacht hat. Dass er so sagt, ist dann so Podiumsdiskussion oder wie auch immer. Und er sagt dazwischen durch, ja, und gestern hat mich Merkel wieder angerufen, damit ich morgen weiß, was ich in den Nachrichten sage. Und dann sagt er so, Quatsch, das wird natürlich niemals stattfinden. Wir reden nie mit denen außer vor Kamera. Und ich hatte ehrlicherweise gedacht, es ist ein bisschen wie beim Boxen. Da ist eine Ecke, da ist eine Ecke. Und man trifft sich wirklich nur zum Sommerinterview. Und scherzt nicht davorher so zusammen.
Wie bei Lanz. Also bei Lanz ist es ja so, dass die Sendung sofort beginnt. Die Gäste werden auch nicht von Lanz nochmal vorher reingedrückt.
Genau, du bist da, Lanz kommt rein, Sendung geht los. Und das ist ja auch, so machen wir auch den Podcast. Also Wolfgang kommt, Podcast geht los. Wir machen doch kein ewiges Vorgespräch wie Lage der Nation, wo man Dienstag erstmal eine Konferenz macht darüber, was man Donnerstag sagt. Und dann käme sie im Kolber, der sagt, egal was Mittwoch passiert. Also das ist alles sehr, sehr, sehr merkwürdig. Aber sie wollen jetzt auch in die inhaltliche Dimension einsteigen. Sie haben Fragen an den Chat.
So, wir schauen einmal auf die Ergebnisse.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt. Oh, ja.
Also sie haben vorher gefragt, wie beliebt ist eigentlich Friedrich Merz bei euch? Ja, und jetzt kommt hier die Aufklärung.
So, wir schauen einmal auf die Ergebnisse.
Jetzt bin ich gespannt. Oh, ja, genau. Das ist dieses klare, deutliche Bild, von dem ich gerade eben sprach, das sich abgezeichnet hat. 48,25 Prozent sagen, sie sind gar nicht zufrieden mit dem Bundeskanzler Friedrich Merz. 28 Prozent sagen, sie sind weniger zufrieden. Zufrieden sind 16,25 Prozent und sehr zufrieden sind 7,5 Prozent.
Okay, echt nicht, gar nicht zufrieden.
Oh krass, gar nicht zufrieden. Also Friedrich Merz hat hier ein Approval Rating von 15,25 Prozent oder so. Das ist noch weiter unter Wasser als Donald Trump oder irgendwas. Er kommt gar nicht gut an. Und die sind jetzt so ein bisschen überrascht und denken sich, oh shit, ob der nächste Jahr noch mal zum Sommer Interview kommt, wenn wir den heute so darstellen. Also, diese beiden Journalisten, also, sagen wir mal, Hosts dieser Sendung, glauben jetzt, es wäre ihre Aufgabe, uns zu erklären, warum Friedrich Merz vielleicht doch nicht und so weiter. Sie wissen aber nicht, wie, weil die Umfrage ging halt so aus.
Vielleicht doch gar nicht so schlecht.
Ja, also wir hören jetzt mal so ein Versuch, uns das irgendwie schönzureden, zu normalisieren.
Er ist noch nicht mal 100 Tage im Amt. Ist man nicht zufrieden mit den Sachen, die man jetzt gesehen hat oder mit den Aussagen, die er tätigt? Und kann man das voneinander trennen?
Du meinst mit den politischen Inhalten sozusagen, seiner Politik, aber auch dann seiner Rhetorik oder wie er sich ausdrückt.
Ja, voll.
Absolut. Absolut.
Ja.
Ja, voll. Ja, absolut. Guck mal einfach an 200.000. Also es ist ein bisschen fragwürdig.
Aber im Prinzip ist das ja, was wir über alle erleben. Also ich meine, Funk ist doch eigentlich nur öffentlich-rechtliches Fernsehen, Mainstream, wie immer, nur mit Tattoos und Nasenringe. Und das ist ja hier auch so.
Genau. Sie haben jetzt Fragen zum Fact-Checking. Denn wenn man einen Vorteil hat in der ARD, dann ist das Ressource, aber typischerweise keine Zeit. Deswegen geht der Sommerinterview nur 30 Minuten, außer man macht es auf Twitch 30 Stunden. Dann hat man natürlich Zeit, Fact-Checking zu machen. Wir fordern es jetzt ein bisschen heraus. Wir lassen uns erklären, wie die Fact-Checking machen. Danach machen wir Fact-Checking von Fact-Checking. Mal gucken, was bei rumkommt. Sie fragen jetzt also erstmal die Fact-Checker, bevor es was zu Fact-Checken gibt, was mit diesem Fact-Checking auf sich hat.
Ja, und viele fragen sich dann immer so, warum geht das nicht schneller oder warum macht ihr die Faktenchecks nicht live? Und wir wollen euch mal ja sagen, was für ein Aufwand da eigentlich dahinter steckt. Und um das zu klären, dafür schalten wir jetzt mal zu unserem Kollegen Pascal Siegelko von den Artifaktenfindern. Hey Pascal.
Moin, heil, ihr beiden.
Und liebe Grüße an den Chat.
Sehr pflichtbewusst. Grüß auf jeden Fall den Chat.
Und dem haben sie aber kein richtiges Mikrofon gegeben, ne, Baris?
Nein, ja niemand. Du siehst das gleich. Niemand hat ein richtiges Mikrofon. Die fliegen alle gleich zum Mond. Die haben Bügelmikrofone, Kopfhörer und alles. Pascal, erklärt uns jetzt mal, warum es ihn gibt und warum man das nicht einfach mit KI machen kann.
Und was viele ja auch immer noch fragen, ist irgendwie, arbeitet ihr mit KI-Tools oder ähnlichem? Wir kennen ja die ganzen Chatbots. But they are also not as reliable as we would like them to be. So that you can just throw a statement of a politician in a Chatbot and say, is that right? And then he gets a reliable answer. But it's just that there are often still mistakes. That you have to check that again. What are the sources that are used there? And that also takes a lot of time. You can't trust the AI.
Die Vermögensverteilung ist so extrem wie noch nie.
So, sofort sehr heikel. Wann kommt die Vermögenssteuer? Also nicht ob und so weiter, sondern wann? Jetzt hören wir die Antwort von Friedrich Merz und danach den Factchecker, der die Antwort einschätzt.
Die Vermögenssteuer kommt gar nicht. Das Bundesverfassungsgericht hat das vor zig Jahren, ich glaube es war in den 80er, 90er Jahren, ausgesetzt, weil die Vermögenssteuer in Deutschland einfach nicht erhoben werden kann, weil jede Form einer Vermögenssteuer gegen den Gleichheitsgrundsatz des Grundgesetzes verstößt. So, wir haben eine progressive Einkommensbesteuerung.
Also offengestanden, ich habe es anders in den Augen.
Ups, jetzt habe ich mich verklickt. Das passiert auch bei Twitch. Ja Pascal, was war da denn eigentlich falsch?
Merz hat in der Aussage gesagt, dass jede Form einer Vermögenssteuer gegen den Gleichheitsgrundsatz des Grundgesetzes verstößt. Und das ist so nicht richtig, weil die Vermögenssteuer an sich ist nicht per se verfassungswidrig. Sie wird im Grundgesetz sogar explizit als mögliche Steuereinnahmequelle genannt. Und worauf sich Merz in diesem Interview auch bezogen hat, ist ein Beschluss des Bundesverfassungsgerichts aus den 90er Jahren. Und in diesem Beschluss, der auch öffentlich zugänglich ist, heißt es, dass die Bemessungsgrundlage, also wie genau die Höhe der Steuern ermittelt werden soll, unvereinbar mit dem Grundgesetz ist. Das heißt aber nicht, dass die Vermögenssteuer an sich quasi verfassungswidrig ist, sondern in dem Fall diese Bemessungsgrundlage.
So, bevor du jetzt was dazu sagst. Wir sehen hier gar nicht den Livestream vom Sommerinterview mit Friedrich Merz. Der war drei Wochen vorher. Wir sehen hier das Vorgespräch des Sommerinterviews mit Felix Banajak. Da lagen drei Wochen dazwischen und man füllt hier im Grunde nur ein bisschen Zeit. Jetzt hast du seine Antwort gehört. Ja, Friedrich Merz hatte nicht so ganz recht, dass eine Vermögenssteuer gar nicht möglich ist, weil das Bundesverfassungsgericht das vor zig Jahren sagte, wegen Bemessungsrundlage. Willst du noch kommentieren, sonst klären wir auf. Ich habe nämlich dann gedacht, ne, das weiß doch Gemini viel besser. Also ich habe Gemini einfach gesagt, Friedrich Merz hat gesagt, eine Vermögensstelle ist in Deutschland unmöglich. Was hat denn das, was steht denn im Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts direkt drin? Zitiere mir. Daraufhin hat Gemini mir drei Sekunden später gesagt, das ist jetzt sehr klein, ich trag's euch vor. Das Gericht stellte zunächst fest, dass die für die Bewertung der Grundvermögen herangezogenen Einheitswerte seit Jahrzehnten nicht mehr angepasst wurden. You can already see in the first sentence up there. You probably can't read it, because it's too small. But the unit values ​​are fattened. So Jeremy Nye already knew. I'm fattening him so that it goes faster with the end of the message. So, from the decision. Also aus dem Beschluss. Das Gericht kritisierte, dass die Hauptfeststellung der Werte seit 1964 nicht mehr stattgefunden hat. Also als das Verfassungsgericht 1995 das vorgelegt bekommen hat, hat es festgestellt, die Grundstücke wurden ja seit 30 Jahren nicht mehr bewertet. Dann hat man Schlussfolgerungen gezogen im Verhältnis zu allen anderen Werten, Bargeldbestände, Aktien und so weiter, die klar berechenbar sind. Liegen die Immobilien im Wert zurück. Also der Bestandswert, der für die Vermögenssteuer herangezogen wurde, lag weit hinter dem Verkehrswert, wie wenn man es heute verkaufen würde. Und dann hat mir Gemini noch gesagt, achte mal hier auf diesen Part. Diese Werte reichen im Bundesdurchschnitt nicht einmal die Hälfte der heutigen Verkehrswerte. Also im ganzen Schnitt hat das Gericht gesagt, die Grundstücke sind um die Hälfte oder weniger zu niedrig bewertet. Ihr müsstet die alle viel höher ansetzen, ihr sammelt zu wenig Vermögenssteuer ein. Und dann diesen letzten Satz aus dem Zitat, in Ballungsräumen liegen die Grundstücke nur noch bei einem Zehntel ihres Verkehrswertes. Das Verfassungskriter hat also gesagt, wenn ihr Grundstücke seht in dem Vermögensbestand, müsst ihr in Großstädten einen Faktor von 10 mindestens drauflegen, sonst ist es ungerecht. Also ich höre da nicht, das Bundesverfassungsgerät hat gesagt, das darf niemals möglich sein und so, sondern nein, die Grundstücke sind zu niedrig bewertet. Und in Ballungsräumen 1995 nur noch 10% der Verkehrswerthöhe. Heute, nochmal 30 Jahre später, würde ich sagen 1%. Also das Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts sagte, wenn jemand besonders viel Vermögen hat, wird er viel zu niedrig vermögensbesteuert. Das ist unfair. Macht das mal neu. Wurde aber nie neu gemacht. Dann habe ich so gedacht, hä, aber es gab doch eine Grundsteuerreform. Also diese Bewertung wurde doch erst vor 3, 4 Jahren neu gemacht.
Gegen die die Bildzeitung ja immer noch täglich mobil macht.
Dann habe ich Gemini gefragt, aber prinzipiell könnte die Grundsteuerreform dazu dienen, die Vermögensteuer wiederzubeleben, da sie genau dieses Problem der Vermögensteuer tangiert. Gemini, die eure Überlegung ist Gold richtig. Also vielleicht, vielleicht hätten der Fact-Checker doch mal bei Gemini einfach nachfragen sollen, um die Frage noch reinreichen zu können, statt irgendwie drei Wochen später da mal aufzuklären. Ist irgendwie komisch. Friedrich Merz weiß, die bei der ARD sind so blöd. Die nutzen nicht mal Internet. Also macht er folgenden Spruch.
Was ist Vermögensteuer? In den meisten Ländern, in denen es eine solche Vermögensteuer gibt, wird sie auf Immobilien erhoben. Und die gibt es in Deutschland. Die heißt in Deutschland Grundsteuer.
Die Grundsteuer ist jetzt plötzlich eine Vermögensteuer. Und zwar auf die Frage, die er sich selbst stellt. Was ist Vermögensteuer? Wie so ein Philosoph, ja? Alle wollen jetzt Robert Habeck werden. Ich gehe also rüber im Browser zu Gemini. Also Friedrich Merz behauptet ja gerade, die Grundsteuer sei eine Vermögensteuer. Hat er recht? Nein. Aus finanz- und steuerrechtlicher Sicht hat er damit nicht recht. Die Grundsteuer und die Vermögensteuer sind sehr grundlegend verschiedene Steuerarten. Und dann die Behauptung, die Grundsteuer sei eine Vermögensteuer, ist politisch motivierend, aber fachlich unzutreffend. Sie dient oft dazu, die Belastungen durch die Grundsteuer als ausreichend darzustellen und Forderungen nach einer echten Vermögenssteuer abzuwehren. Ich sehe uns also schon nächstes Jahr hier sitzen, wenn du sagst, also was die Politiker mit ihrer Forderung nach Vogue AI fordern, das geht so weit. Weil das kann sich Friedrich Merz auch nicht lange bieten lassen.
Jaja eben.
Dass hier einfach jeder auf Zuhuf... Nee, Friedrich Merz ist wirklich blöd, als er Antwort bekommt.
Nein, man müsste ja eigentlich jetzt... Man müsste ja jetzt eigentlich nur noch in das Smart TV Gemini inkludieren und das läuft quasi als Untertitel mit. Ja, das wäre ja durchaus möglich.
Wir machen das irgendwie bei der Verwöchentlichkeit, weil wir haben eine Bemessungsgrundlage und wollen jetzt wissen, wie weit unter Wasser sind wir gerade? Und dann ist der Pegel immer ein Prozent, zwei Prozent, ein Prozent. So, jetzt eine echte Herausforderung für den Faktencheck, den wir natürlich überspringen wollen. Wir machen uns selber dazu Gedanken. Die Herausforderung ist jetzt für dich, Wolfgang. Wir hören jetzt Felix Banachak auf eine Frage im Sommerinterview. Wir versuchen zuzuhören, zu verstehen, was er uns sagen will. Du bietest uns danach einen Faktencheck oder einen Vibecheck oder was auch immer. Du kannst dir aussuchen, ja?
Will er jetzt der neue Habeck werden?
Hier, Felix Banachak für dich.
Was würden Sie denn? Was wollen Sie anders machen? Und das bitte kurz und knapp.
Man darf Radikalität im Sinne von an die Wurzel gehen, ja nicht mit Verbalradikalismus verwechseln. Ich möchte, dass die Grünen die Partei bleiben, eine Partei in dem Sinne der radikalen Ehrlichkeit, die benennt, welche Probleme wir haben, die auch ehrlich ist, dass es mit Zumutungen einhergeht, diese Probleme zu lösen, die sich daran macht, diese Zumutungen fair zu verteilen und abzufedern und dadurch mehr Menschen erreicht als bisher. Und jetzt habe ich in den letzten Tagen gesehen, manche Menschen haben Angst vor einem Linksruck. Und ich kann da allen sagen, wer Sorge hat vor einem Ruck nach links, nach rechts, nach oben oder nach unten, fürchtet euch nicht, die Grünen werden jetzt wieder grüner.
Also kein Linksruck und radikale Offenheit, aber keine radikalen Lösungen. Das nehmen wir schon mal mit an.
Radikale Lösungen schon in dem Sinne, dass wir, wenn die Welt sich verändert und zwar in einem Tempo, wie wir das lange nicht hatten, kann doch keiner sagen, liebe Leute, keine Sorge an euch, wird das alles vorbeigehen. Das ist ja das Modell Scholz, entteilen auch das Modell Merz. Und dafür stehen die Grünen nicht zur Verfügung. Wir haben harte Entscheidungen zu treffen. Die Klimakrise löst sich nicht von allein. Wir werden der Erosion unserer regelbasierten Weltordnung nicht durchzugucken gerecht. Und wenn ich mir anschaue, dass überall auf der Welt der Rechtsextremismus, der Faschismus erstarkt, dann müssen wir auch darüber sprechen, was wir dagegen tun.
Aber das wollen wir machen.
Ja, das klingt nach einem ganz klaren Programm. Also erst mal die Absage daran, dass man eine linke Partei sein will. Das kann man sich schon mal merken. Und zweitens Radikalität an die Wurze gehen. Aber so, dass es zwar eine Zumutung sein kann, die aber auch abgefedert ist für alle, die diese Zumutung betreffen könnte, wenngleich auch klar sein muss, dass man den Menschen etwas zumuten muss. Denn die radikale Katastrophe durch Klima ist da und sowieso die geopolitischen Herausforderungen.
Und du musst am Ende noch sagen, und das wollen wir jetzt machen.
Und das wollen wir jetzt machen. Ja, also ich habe beeindruckend, er muss natürlich noch diesen Hardback Sound dafür drauf bekommen, dann geht das kniffliger durch. Aber das ist wirklich, wenn man sagt, also man kann es sich leicht machen in der Antwort und sagen, wir stehen für fast nichts, aber man kann es natürlich auch ausführlich beantworten.
Also ich dachte hier natürlich jetzt an Ilja Sutzkeffer, den großen KI-Chef da, der ja gesagt hat, ja, das mit der KI ist eben so, sie löst, also sie hat unverständliche Antworten, weil wir ihr ja unverständliche Probleme geben. Und das trifft ja hier auf jeden Fall zu. Ich habe versucht, jetzt irgendwas rauszuholen. Also ich habe es transkribieren lassen, habe Terminal gefragt, was will er von mir und so weiter. Und dann bin ich drauf gekommen, ich stelle mir jetzt mal vor oder die KI soll sich vorstellen, zu wem spricht er da gerade? Frank Staus sagt ja immer als Wahlkämpfer, ja man hat so eine Person, man entwickelt so eine Person, der 50-jährige Innenstädter, der einen kurzen Arbeitsweg hat. Wie würde der auf diese oder jene politische Initiative reagieren?
So Sinusmilieus versucht man dann auszuwerden.
Und ich habe mir jetzt gedacht, Felix Banaszak hat wahrscheinlich so einen Habeg liebhaber im Kopf, der zu Hause sitzt und so ein bisschen bedauert, dass die grünische wieder eine neue Spitze, wer ist denn dieser Neue da? And Gemini bzw. Google VEO heißt das ja, das macht so acht sekundenlange Videos, kam mit dieser Antwort. Ihr werdet daran erkennen, dass sie natürlich kaif fake ist, weil die Person nur auf Englisch sprechen kann, aber ich glaube, wir werden es verstehen.
Wow, someone on television talks like Robert Abbeck.
I really missed my philosopher.
Ich glaube, das ist...
Sehr schön.
Auf diese Person ist es gemünzt. Das ist Politik für die 1%.
Es ist Operpolitik, aber man trägt nur Rundhals-T-Shirt und nicht mehr ein richtiges Hemd unterm Sacko. Aber machst du ja auch.
Ja, klar. Und so sitzen sie in diesem Stream und hören sich einfach Banaschak an.
Und ja, ich glaube auch, dass bei der Frage, wie schützen wir eigentlich unsere Gesellschaft vor dem Auseinanderbrechen? Akzeptieren wir, dass die soziale Ungleichheit immer größer wird? Dass Armut anwächst und gleichzeitig bei einigen wenigen der Reichtum immer, immer, immer größer wird? Braucht es dafür Radikalität in der Analyse? Ja, und es braucht eine Politik, die bereit ist, dann auch diese Fragen zu stellen. Aber nicht mit Klassenkampf, nicht mit sozusagen Radikalisierung in den Worten. Das halte ich für einen Fehler. Es geht ja darum, Mehrheiten für eine solche Politik zu erreichen und nicht die Menschen abzustoßen. Aber das tue ich nicht, indem ich beschwichtige, in welcher Zeit wir leben. Es geht um eine Politik der Ehrlichkeit und der Empathie.
Vielen Dank, Herr Banaschak. Das war Tagesschau Together nach dem Sommer-Interview. Vielen Dank fürs Zuschauen.
Ehrlichkeit, Empathie, Achtsamkeit hätte er noch sagen können. Ist auch ein schönes Wort.
Ich hätte tatsächlich auch Grünchef werden können. Ich habe mich ja nur als Grünpopulismusbeauftragte beworfen, aber ich hätte direkt das Angebot machen müssen.
Ja, ob das dann so läuft, wie die sich das vorstellen, weiß ich nicht. Also das ist ja auch schon so ein Entre-Bilet für alle weiteren Gespräche mit Jagoda Marinic, der so verhandeln kann. Das ist eine Kampelsprache. Ja, das ist so ein gewisses Panel sprechen. Also man kann so einfach am Tag mindestens vier, fünf Panels machen in Deutschland und dann wieder zurück in den ICE.
Ich glaube, wenn Banaszak so in den Podcasts von Karolin Ehmke geht, reden die sechs Stunden.
Ja.
Versteht sich gut.
Jetzt allerdings jemand anders, Jan van Aken von den Linken. Er bekommt hier mal eine Frage. Menschen, die uns schon länger zuhören, werden meine Antwort auf diese Frage kennen.
Sie sagen, es soll keine Milliardäre geben.
Wie sieht es mit Millionären aus?
Sind die okay?
So, sie sagen, es soll keine Milliardäre geben. Was ist denn mit Millionären? Darauf ist natürlich die richtige Antwort. Liebe Frau Journalistin, wissen Sie, was der Unterschied zwischen einer Milliarde und einer Million ist? Eine Milliarde. Denn eine Million ist eine 0,1 Prozent Milliarde. Die kann man immer schnell wegrunden. Jan von Aaken hat diese Antwort nicht, aber er macht eine vielleicht sogar bessere. Denn ich war auch überrascht. Wir hören jetzt einen Fakt, den können wir uns alle hinter die Ohren oder gleich ins Parteibuch schreiben. Das ist wirklich krass. Also ich wusste das nicht. Wir machen danach einen Factcheck.
Ich finde, ich habe überhaupt nichts gegen Reichtum. Mal ganz ehrlich, wir wollen doch alle irgendwie reich sein. Ich denke auch immer, wenn mir jetzt jemand zwei Millionen geben würde, Hängematte am Strand, finde ich echt in Ordnung. Aber ab einem bestimmten Punkt wird das unverschämt. Und eine Milliarde ist so viel Geld, die hat kein Mensch gearbeitet. Wissen Sie, ich habe das mal ausgerechnet. Susanne Klatten ist eine der reichsten Frauen Deutschland, hat viele Milliarden. Die hat in einem Jahr mal eine Stunde Lohn bekommen von 1,1 Millionen Euro. Ich sage Ihnen, niemand kann so hart arbeiten oder so klug sein, dass sie 1,1 Millionen Euro die Stunde verdient.
Wenn man von BMW eine Milliarde überwiesen kriegt, Dividende, und das runterbricht auf 52 Wochen, 40 Wochenstunden, ein bisschen Urlaubstage, acht Stundentage, stellt sich raus, also mein Prom Susanne Klatten, alle Einkommen von ihr zusammengenommen, kommt sie in manchen Jahren auf ein rechnerisches Stundenlohn von eine Million Euro oder mehr? Antworten möglichst kurz. Antwort, ja, es gibt Berechnungen, die darauf hindeuten, dass Susanne Klattens rechnerischer Stundenlohn mancher, in manchen Jahren eine Million Euro übersteigen kann.
Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass das Team von Jan van Aten weiß, was Cheche Pt.
Ich glaube auch. Wenn auch Defektchecker, das ist dann Defektgenerator, die haben es drauf. Also das ist wirklich erstaunlich. Ein Stundenlohn von eine Million Euro das ganze Jahr hindurch.
Crazy.
Jan von Agen kriegt hier eine Frage, die finde ich so naheliegend. Ich glaube, wir alle wissen die Antwort.
Wenn die Linke nach der nächsten Bundestagswahl mitregieren könnte, welchen Posten hätten sie dann gerne?
So, hier wird ein deutscher Bundestagsabgeordneter gefragt. Welchen Posten in einer möglichen Regierung hätten sie denn gerne? Wir kennen die eine Antwort. Alle anderen wären gelogen. Das wissen wir auch.
Niemand sagt, ich wollte immer mal Innenminister sein.
Ich wollte schon immer für den Sport zuständig sein. Also jetzt hören wir Jan van Aken's Antwort, weil er einfach ganz populistisch ist.
Also ich bin jetzt 64. Ehrlich gesagt würde ich nur noch Kanzler machen oder in Rente gehen.
Kanzler oder Rente? Also ich habe bisher einen Jan von Aken gehört, von dem ich sehe, der kann KI bedienen. Der weiß ungefähr, auf welchem Niveau er Fragen bekommt, breitet sich darauf vor. Er möchte gerne Kanzler werden, statt wenn mich der Ruf ereilt, rumzudrucksen. Jetzt allerdings, es ist ja eine sehr lange Sendung, man hat unglaublich viele Stunden zu füllen in diesem Stream. Und das machen sie ja auch. Fact-Checking, Einordnungen, Hintergründe zu den Linken.
Die Linke haut ja auch gern mal so ein paar zugespitzte, um es vorsichtig auszudrücken, Forderungen raus, beispielsweise Milliardäre abschaffen oder auch eine Vermögenssteuer einführen etc. Wie realistisch sind solche Forderungen? Nicht?
Nicht?
Ja, ja, also ich sag, ich sag ja, also die, die jungen Leute im öffentlich- hessischen Fernsehen sind eigentlich die Schlimmsten. Also das ist meine Erfahrung damit. Mit Funk und so weiter. Also die, die norden wirklich nochmal jeden jungen Menschen ein, dass es diese gute Mitte gibt. Und alles, was darüber hinaus geht, ist irgendwie radikal, spinnert, extrem. Man weiß es nicht so recht.
Wir hören mal seine Antwort im Detail.
Milliardäre abschaffen, das ist halt so ein Ding.
Da schütteln dann Leute, die irgendwie vielleicht so ein bisschen auch sympathisieren würden mit der Linke den Kopf, weil es ist so, wie willst du das machen?
Also dann führt es die Leute nur dazu, dass sie halt irgendwie nach Liechtenstein ziehen oder nach Luxemburg oder nach Frankreich oder irgendwas.
Es ist einfach so ein bisschen auf dem Putzraum.
Und deshalb sind, glaube ich, doch einige Ideen, die da ventiliert werden, einige Ideen, die die Leute äußern, von der Linken relativ unrealistisch. Kann man denn jetzt gar nichts machen, lieber Journalist? Als ich meine Milliardäre abschaffe und man nimmt die einfach die Milliarden weg, fertig ist, kann man gar nichts machen. Es kommt drauf an. Manche Forderungen sind irgendwie machbar. Was ein Punkt ist, den sie immer wieder gerne nennen, ist die Vermögenssteuer. Wir hatten mal eine Vermögenssteuer, die wurde dann außer Kraft gesetzt.
Insofern, es ist nicht gänzlich unmöglich.
Andere Länder hatten die, manche hatten gute Erfahrungen, manche hatten eher schlechte Erfahrungen. Länder hatten schlechte Erfahrungen. Wir hören jetzt mal Details.
Aber wie realistisch sind diese Umverteilungsforderungen der Linken? Eher unrealistisch, ehrlich gesagt. Wir hatten es vorhin mal ganz kurz vor einer Vermögenssteuer.
Gab es mal, gibt es nicht mehr, gab es in anderen Ländern.
Frankreich ist ein ziemlich berühmtes Beispiel.
Die haben ziemlich reingehauen und das hat dazu geführt, dass Gerard Depardieu zum Beispiel, deren fettester, größter Schauspieler versucht hat auszuwandern. Also das ist dann, wenn du halt die Leute zu sehr schröpfst an der Spitze, dann ist halt immer die Angst, dass die einfach abhauen und wegziehen. Und dann steht das Land ganz ohne dieses Steuernahmen da. Ja, plötzlich dann Frankreich ohne Gerard Depardieu da. Jetzt haben wir die Frage an Filmanalist Wolfgang Emschmidt. Ist Gerard Depardieu der fetteste Schauspieler Frankreich?
Ich bringe mich natürlich jetzt in Teufels Küche, weil Gerard Depardieu nun gerade einige ernsthafte Prozesse gegen ihn erleben muss. Und der ist ein bedeutender Schauspieler, der privat ziemlich eigenartig ist und ja auch viel in Putins Reich unterwegs war.
Im Übrigen aber ja die ganze Zeit auch in Frankreich Filme machte. Und einen Schauspieler rauszupicken ist natürlich jetzt auch so interessant, weil der Schauspieler ja kein Unternehmen hat. Also der hat ja nur sich verkauft sich und bekommt diese horrenden Summen. Kann natürlich dann sagen, er lebt irgendwo anders. Für die Unternehmer wissen wir, dass das gar nicht so einfach ist zu sagen, dann bau doch mal irgendwo in Lichtenstein die BMW-Werke auf.
Ich habe El Hotso gesehen, der gesagt hat, die Schwarzgruppe dürfen wir nicht verbrellen, sonst gehen die und nehmen ihre 3000 Lidl-Filialen mit.
Ja, richtig.
Und dann haben wir alle Hunger. Okay, der Stream geht noch ewig lang. Wir müssen uns noch ein bisschen darüber informieren, was es jetzt mit diesen linken Firlefans auf sich hat.
Ja, wenn es in Deutschland keine Milliardäre gibt, dann gehen die Milliardären andere Länder zahlen, dort steuern und tragen zur Wertschöpfung und zur Wirtschaftsleistung bei.
Veronika Grimm ist jetzt in einem Twitch-Stream zugeschaltet? Oder wie ist das?
Jaja.
Also man geht zu Twitch und wird selbst da nicht von Veronika Grimm in Ruhe gelassen?
Ja, genau. Aber nicht nur Veronika Grimm, man hat noch ein paar andere gefunden.
Wir sehen hier auch teilweise populistische Elemente, namely dieses Element der Elitenkritik, das eben im Gegensatz aufgemacht wird zwischen der hart arbeitenden Bevölkerung auf der einen Seite und quasi der unverdienten Superreichen auf der anderen Seite.
Ja, das geht nicht, das ist populistisch.
Ja, nee, das geht wirklich nicht.
Es gibt noch mehr.
Eine Vermögenssteuer ist ziemlich ineffektiv. Es gibt relativ wenig Steuereinnahmen für einen sehr großen Aufwand.
Ich weiß, dass es genau umgedreht ist bei der Vermögenssteuer. Ja.
Also wir wissen ja, was sehr ineffektiv ist, irgendwelchen Bürgergeldempfängern hinterherzuwenden, ob die 50 Euro zu viel bekommen haben. Das ist ineffektiv.
Also drei Jahre Christian Lindner bedeutet, dass die Steuerprüfungen um 60 Prozent nach unten gegangen sind, weshalb jetzt fünf Milliarden weniger eingenommen werden. Fünf bis sechs Milliarden ist die Schärzung. Naja, Klima-Soli.
Wir brauchen ein Klima-Soli für die obersten zehn Prozent. Ein Klima-Soli, das die für ihre Klimaverbrechen bezahlen.
Die Idee ist, dass das Wort Verbrechen als Metapher genutzt wird, um zu provozieren, um Aufmerksamkeit zu schaffen, um auch darauf hinzuweisen, dass das moralisch nicht korrekt ist, um damit wiederum eine politische Forderung, nämlich nach dem Klima-Soli einzuleiten.
Ja, das ist ja eine Wahnsinnsanalyse. Unglaublich.
Da kennt man mal niemand von der Welt.
Da bin ich auch froh, dass ich Germanistik studiert habe, dass ich all den folgen kann.
Das Wort Verbrechen, was ist eigentlich ein Verbrechen? Was ist eine Vermögenssteuer? Eine Vermögenssteuer ist ein Verbrechen, würde ich mal sagen. So, jetzt zurück ins Sommerinterview.
Ich will nur nochmal anknüpfen an unseren ersten Teil, ja? Wenn diese ganzen Zensurmaßnahmen kommen, dann haben wir nur noch sowas.
Ja, genau. Ich bin überzeugt.
Dann sind wir ein paar hat ruhig geknallt.
So zurück im Sommerinterview. Jetzt ist wieder ein bisschen Fairness, zumindest auf der Ebene, dass Jan van Aken reagieren darf, statt hier einfach nur im Bild zu stehen, während irgendwelche Leute irgendwas über ihn sagen.
Wenn Sie hergehen und sagen, Milliardäre soll es nicht geben. Und auch bei den Millionären haben Sie schon mal gesagt, 100 Millionen, wer soll denn sagen, wie viel man haben darf, wie viel man besitzen darf? Wer entscheidet das?
Wir haben 82 Millionen Menschen, das gibt Wahlen, da kann man drüber abstimmen.
So, also er sagt, die Antwort ist ja schon sehr kurz. Man könnte sie nochmal verkürzen. Wir lösen es demokratisch. Jetzt glaubt aber nicht, dass irgendwer dort das versteht. Da sitzen zwei Journalisten im Gespräch, plus der Fact-Checker da nochmal eine Einschätzung macht. Und ihr hört jetzt an den Nachfragen und so weiter. Jan van Agen redet sich den Mundfusselig. Er wird hier wirklich nicht verstanden.
Also ich sage ja nicht, dass alle das Gleiche haben sollen, aber es muss eine Grenze geben.
Aber wer, das war auch gerade bei uns im Gespräch, wer setzt diese Grenze? Also, weil Bundestagswahl hatten sie ja einmal genannt, aber das ist ja so, so kann man ja nicht regieren. Also Bundestagswahl ist ja alle vier Jahre, wenn man konkrete Entscheidungen treffen will. Wer soll das machen in Ihrer Vorstellung?
Wir alle. Wir haben 82 Millionen Menschen hier und da macht man eben eine Volksabstimmung. Ich bin hier dafür, dass es bundesweite Volksabstimmung gibt. Und dann sagt man, findet ihr den Faktor 10 oder den Faktor 20 am besten? Also soll der Chef einer Firma das 20-Fache verdienen, wie das geringste Geld oder nur das 10-Fache? Da kann man doch darüber abstimmen. Da gibt es ja logische Argumente, aber irgendwo muss eine Grenze rein.
Und so viel würden Sie stimmen?
Ich finde, 20 ist echt eine Obergrenze.
20 Millionen?
Nee, das 20-Fache verdienen. Also ich habe einen großen Faktor und die einfachste Arbeit wird bezahlt, jetzt hat er eigentlich zwei, fünf Produkte, dann darf der oberste Chef maximal das 20-Fache verdienen und da ist Ende gelände.
Okay, kommen wir zur nächsten Frage. Geht's in der Ende?
Auch da wieder. Das klingt irgendwie so, ja, macht voll Sinn irgendwie so. Der verdient so viel, der verdient 20-fach mehr. Das ist super viel mehr. Der lebt immer noch ein gutes Leben. Das klingt doch irgendwie gerecht. Aber es geht halt an eine Realität vorbei. Weil genau da das Ding ist, wenn wir in Deutschland so was einführen würden und so eine Grenze kappen würden, dann würde doch alle Leute, die eventuell diese Arbeit auf sich nehmen wollen, die in den meisten Fällen wahrscheinlich sackhart ist oder wirklich einfach einen Knochenjob irgendwie hast, auch als Chef. Dann will ich sagen, weißt du was, dann gehe ich nach Amerika, dann gehe ich nach Frankreich, dann gehe ich nach Schweden, nach Großbritannien, irgendwo hin, wo es die Grenze nicht gibt. Und dann hast du da die ganzen Leute, die wirklich gut Unternehmen fühlen, weil sie sich sagen, warum soll ich dann irgendwie quasi die gleiche Arbeit machen, aber so krass gekappt werden? Und das ist eine nette Idee. Das mag manchen irgendwie so entsprechen. Das heißt ja 20-faches Gehalt meines Angestellten, das ist irgendwie gerecht. Aber es ist halt nicht umsetzbar. Und das ist halt ein großes Problem mit dieser Idee.
Der Witz ist ja auch immer, dass so getan wird, als könnte man einfach irgendwo hingehen und bekommt da sofort diesen spitzen Job. Also das gilt ja schon die ganze Zeit. Wenn wir jetzt die Spitzenlöhne vergleichen mit den Spitzenlöhnen in den USA, dann dürfte ja kein einziges spitzen Personal mehr zu finden sein. Die werden nämlich alle in den USA, denn da verdienen sie bestimmt zehnmal so viel. Aber sie gehen ja komischerweise nicht, vielleicht weil sie da gar nicht so sehr gewollt sind. Und ja, dann kommt auch wirklich dieses Argument, die auch einen Knochenjob machen und da arbeiten. Stimmt, Unternehmer arbeiten jetzt härter als die beim Öffentlich-Rechtlichen. Aber so hart hier war er auch nicht.
Ja, der kleine Barman-Manager ist ein harter Job. Van Aken betont jetzt nochmal den Fluchtgedanken.
El Magnifico, interessanter Name bei YouTube, fragt, inwiefern profitiert Deutschland durch eine Vermögenssteuer und wie stellt man sicher, dass Investitionen und Kapital im Land bleiben, haben Sie ja vorhin auch schon so ein bisschen drüber gesprochen.
Also erster Punkt kommt natürlich darauf an, wie man sie gestaltet. Unser Vorschlag würde im Jahr 108 Milliarden bringen, was richtig viel Geld ist. Aber da gehört eben auch zu, dass man über eine Milliarde 12 Prozent nimmt, mehr als es früher in Deutschland war. Und die Frage, wie verhindert man das, die abhauen? Die hauen nicht ab. Das gibt wunderbare Studien dazu, auch aus anderen Ländern, dass die, die so viel Geld haben, die haben mit diesem Geld vor allem Macht und Einfluss, aber nur in ihrem Land. So, deswegen ist die Erfahrung, dass sie nicht abhauen. Und zweitens haben wir in Deutschland schon eine Wegzugsteuer. Wenn jetzt plötzlich so ein Aldi-Erbe mit seinen 7 Milliarden sagen würde, ich gehe jetzt woanders hin, dann muss er 50 Prozent Steuern zahlen. Deswegen gehen die alle nicht.
Ja, wir schließen hier mal das Vermögenssteuer, um 22 Uhr noch ein Thema aufzumachen, Krieg. Jan von Agen im Gespräch zum Thema Krieg.
Donald Trump bleibt an Bord, sagt der Bundeskanzler, er hat Friedrich Merz alles richtig gemacht?
Ich glaube, er irrt. Ich glaube, Friedrich Merz sollte mal zwei Schritte zurücktreten. Als ich diese Inszenierung in Alaska am Freitag gesehen habe, dachte ich nur, jo.
Jo.
Hab ich auch gedacht, ehrlich gesagt. Bisschen connected gefühlt mit diesem Mann. Er versucht jetzt mal mit der Journalistin in ein Gespräch zu kommen.
Oh, das ist eine ganz gefährliche Sache.
Das habe ich mir ja immer gewünscht.
Ich glaube, das hat das letzte Mal Carla Hinrichs versucht bei Anne Will. Als Anne Will immer sagt, ja, aber glauben Sie, dass das wirklich weiterhilft? Dass er irgendwann sagte, ja, aber was soll denn weiterhelfen? Sagen Sie es mir. Und Anne Will guckt ja dann so ganz verdurzt wie ich.
Ich stelle hier doch nur auf Fragen. Ich bin hier nur auf der Fragen. Also darauf läuft es hier auch hinaus. Jan van Aken macht meine Anmerkung.
Wir sitzen hier heute in Berlin und während wir hier sitzen, fährt gerade vor Fehmarn wahrscheinlich ein Tanker längst mit illegalem russischen Öl. Das ist die Einnahmen aus dem Ölverkauf, gehen direkt in die Kriegskasse. Damit wird der Krieg finanziert.
So, wir haben das auch schon thematisiert. Arte, die Nuklearfalle, das mit dem Öl.
Bisschen ja auch.
Jetzt ein kleines Fernsehhighlight.
Wenn ich richtig informiert bin, geht es ja in dem 18. Sanktionspaket der EU auch um Schiffe der Schattenflotte.
Können Sie mir erklären, warum das erst im 18. und nicht im 1. passiert ist? Das ist das Versagen der deutschen Bundesrepublik.
Das ist nicht meine Aufgabe, Ihnen das zu erklären.
Also ich werde ja mit Mick am Dienstag wieder überprüfen, ob die Journalisten wirklich nicht für sich als Aufgabe sehen, uns zu erklären, was ist mit dem Krieg und Putin und so auf sich die ganze Zeit.
Ja, die ganze Zeit erklären Sie die ganze Zeit, wie wir es sehen müssen. Aber wenn Sie dann selbst mal dazu befragt werden, auf einen Widerspruch hingewiesen werden, ja, da bin ich nicht für zuständig.
Aber es ist ja ein Stream. Die machen ja Reaction. Da sitzt also jetzt ein Fact-Checker mit dem Gespräch. Da klärt uns jetzt auf.
Ja, ist spannend. Ich muss zugeben, ich hab jetzt diese ganzen Ölwege, wo auf welchen Tanker eingeladen wird, wo dann raffiniert dann wieder zurückgeschickt wird. Das ist ein bisschen too much für mich. Da bin ich nicht der Ex-Leiter für.
Sorry, ich weiß nicht.
Dann lassen wir's.
Ja, ich hab gehört, Putin hat jedes Jahr 100 Milliarden extra. Woher? Das ist too much für mich, keine Ahnung.
Lass uns lieber nochmal darüber diskutieren, ob Rittersport noch weiter produzieren darf in Russland. Das ist viel richtiger.
Felix Banaschak erklärt uns jetzt kurz das mit dem Krieg.
Wenn ich über Fragen von Krieg und Frieden spreche oder über andere existenzielle Krisen, dann kann ich meine Position nicht von wöchentlich wechselnder Demoskopie abhängig machen. Je nachdem, ob jetzt gerade die Todesstrafe beliebt ist oder nicht, andere ich meine Position dazu. Sondern was ich ernst nehmen muss, ist, dass es den Grünen in den letzten Jahren nicht gelungen ist, diesen Begriff des Friedens für sich zu reklamieren. Und dass es den Falschen gelungen ist, den Friedensbegriff zu kapern. Das ist die Verantwortung, die wir tragen. Aber in der Sache gibt es keinen Grund, unsere Position zu ändern.
Ja, die Falschen haben halt den Friedensbegriff gekapert. Und das ist das größte Problem der deutschen Politik. Von Friedrich Merz hören wir auch noch kurz. Friedrich Merz erklärt uns kurz, warum wir jetzt alle zur Bundeswehr gehen sollten. Zumindest für eine Grundausbildung und so weiter.
Ich bin ja der erste Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, der in der Bundeswehr Wehrdienst geleistet hat. Und ich muss sagen, ich möchte diese Zeit nicht missen. Because for the first time I was in a room with five other men. For several weeks. I got to know completely different social classes. Which I only got to know until then. I saw people from other federal states. That was an exciting time for me. Ich habe mich am Rande kennengelernt habe. Ich habe Menschen aus anderen Bundesländern gesehen. Das war für mich eine spannende Zeit. Ich habe Hierarchie presentieren müssen. Und noch mal, das war für mich eine gute Zeit.
Ich meine, das kriegt man auch anders hin. Hier sind zum Beispiel auch Leute aus anderen Bundesländern. Wenn die wollen, können die sich auch Etagenbetten in einem Hostel noch nehmen. Man fragt sich aber auch, warum sollte man mit fünf Männern auf einem Zimmer rumhocken monatelang? Weiß ich nicht. Aber er hat auch mal Leute gesehen, so aus anderen sozialen Schichten, die man ja sonst so, an denen man sonst so vorbeigeht oder die einen bedienen wollte eigentlich sagen.
Hatte vor 60 Jahren mal Kontakte geknüpft.
Ja, und das ist ja bis heute geblieben. Er ist ja Klassenkämpfer noch immer.
So, Mick hat uns ja Fragen sortiert. Wir gucken noch zwei Clips. Wir kürzen hier ein bisschen, vielleicht den Rest dann mit Mick. Wir wollen noch kurz verstehen, was die hier unter Journalismus verstehen. Typischerweise sagt man immer, ich bin das und das, um damit so eine Distinktion aufzumachen. Also ich mache etwas, was ihr offenbar nicht macht. Ich bin nämlich, keine Ahnung, Raketenbauer oder so. Hier hören wir jetzt die Amerika-Korrespondentin, die auch wieder in so einer ewig langen Live-Schalte die ganze Zeit erklären kann. Und dann kommt immer doch noch eine Nachfrage und so. Was ist jetzt Journalismus? Wie versteht sie ihr Dasein als Amerika-Korrespondentin? Was sind die Aufgaben?
Und im Prinzip, ich fange hier morgens so gegen sechs an, höre mir die ersten Podcasts an. Und dann ist man im Prinzip die ganze Zeit damit beschäftigt, zu gucken, was kommt, was kommt. Und bevor ich abends schlafen gehe, werfe ich einen letzten Blick auf true social. Und manchmal wacht man auf und am nächsten Morgen sieht die Welt dann wieder ganz anders aus.
Auf jeden Fall machst du einen Blick aus deinem Alltag.
Vielen, vielen Dank.
Und wir haben auch noch mal eine Appreciation aus dem Chat.
An Jauli hat geschrieben, ich finde es total cool, das Set da mal zu sehen.
Also da, wo du gerade vor dem weißen Haus stehst.
Ja, richtig cool. Da ist gar kein Set. Sie steht nur mit einem Mikrofon da und einem Kameramann. Und ich habe auch gedacht, ich bin Amerika-Kosmodent.
Morgens den Daily Podcast hörst du schon. Abends guckst du nochmal bei Truths to Social.
Das muss ich jetzt so einführen dann. Ich habe bisher abends nicht auf Truths to Social geguckt. Also ich sag noch mal als abschließenden Clip.
Wir bekommen immer E-Mails. Ich habe eben eine E-Mail bekommen vom sogenannten Press Pool. Das sind die Journalistinnen und Journalisten, die den Präsidenten immer begleiten. Er ist jetzt beim Golfen. Das wissen wir. Er truths gerade weiter, hat eben geschrieben, es gäbe große Fortschritte, was Russland angeht. Und wir sollten also stay tuned, hat er geschrieben.
Also geht sie jetzt nicht schlafen, weil der Präsident hat geschrieben, stay tuned.
Ich freue mich immer, wenn Donald Trump auf dem Golfplatz ist, denn in der Zeit kann er sonst nichts anrichten.
Ja, es ist wirklich grandios.
Wir greifen jetzt mal zu Fragen. Mick hat hier da einiges zusammengestellt. Das ist der gute Stapel. Und was heißt der Schlechte? Was erwartet einen dort? Linker Patriotismus. Was ist Linker Patriotismus? Okay, wir gucken erst mal die guten Fragen. Wir teilen das so ein bisschen auf. Frage an Wolfgang, die kannst du zum Beispiel vorlesen.
Die Idee kam von Wolfgang und ich frage euch nach einem Save-Wort, dass man reinrufen kann und dann ist Schluss. Aber es müssen, sagen wir mal, drei Leute...
Nein, jetzt lass uns das mal anfangen. Sonst schreien die direkt. Also, wollen wir gemeinsam dieses Jahr die Einherz-für-Kinder-Gala stürmen?
Stürmen?
Das ist doch eine Frage an alle, ja.
So teuer ist ja nicht. Ich bringe wieder 4001 Euro mit. Da bin ich der Zampano des Arms.
Ja.
Frage an Wolfgang. Wie viele Labubus möchtest du deiner aus angefangenen Sammlung hinzufügen?
Kein weiteres. Und ich muss auch gestehen. Ich habe dieses Labubu verschenkt und es freuen sich jetzt die beiden Kinder meines Kameramanns. So edel ist die Tat jetzt auch nicht. Ich wusste einfach nicht wohin mit dem scheußlichen Ding.
Hier ist eine Frage. Was sagt es über diesen Podcast aus, das am Herrenklo gerade eine längere Schlange war als am Darmklo? Ich glaube, hier sind einfach hochqualitativere Frauen.
Es müssen mehr Frauen werden, sagt uns das natürlich. Wenn ihr, oh, das ist interessant, wenn ihr gemeinsam in den Urlaub fahren müsstet, auf welche Reise könntet ihr euch einigen?
Worauf dann mit einigen?
Urlaub, Reise, gemeinsam.
Als Destination? Phantasialand?
Da meinste, da komm ich nicht weg oder was? Da kann man gut auf mich aufpassen.
Das ist eine sehr gated community. Da musst du erstmal Mystery Castle, Taron.
Ich denke, wenn dann doch eher, du hast ja schon sehr von geschwärmt, also dann doch eher Italien, Rom.
Nach Umbrien, wir beide im Cabrio.
Ja, ich wollte ja dann fahren. Da ist ja gar kein Führerschein.
Ich flieg nach Rom und du fährst mit dem Cabrio runter und holst mich ab und dann...
Ja.
Wie viele Romane hat Stefan seit dem letzten Sommersala gelesen?
Das war erfolgreich, ja. Lieber mit Hoss und Hopf einen Hopfen trinken oder mit Ronzheimer Champagner trinken?
Na, Champagner.
Ich würde auch doch allein wegen des Champagnas. Also Champagner mit Hoss und Hopf, das wäre natürlich, würde die Frage nochmal verändern. Aber ich bleib beim Champagner.
In den guten Champagner-Träger geschlossenen Augen. Your liebstes Musical. Also meins ist völlig klar. Jeder hier im Saal weiß Bescheid.
Bei mir ist es Hello Dolly.
König der Löwen.
Ich wollte jetzt mal diesen bösen Stapel gucken, was das ist. Laut einer Studie von Henry Partners leben in Frankfurt circa 100.000 Millionäre. Was macht das mit dem Miteinander in der Stadt? Aber das sind doch gute Fragen. Wie ist das Miteinander? Wie ist das Miteinander? Hier sind 100.000 Millionäre, leben in Frankfurt. Wie ist da das Miteinander?
Gut.
Sie zeigen sich ja nicht.
Sie geben sich selten zu erkennen. Ich glaube wirklich, dass das das Ding ist.
Was macht euch Hoffnung? Das hatten wir doch vorhin schon irgendwie, oder? Ist schon abgehakt, muss man nicht nochmal sagen.
Dann haben wir hier bitte eine Büroknose. Wie lange hält die März-Regierung noch? Und woran zerbricht sie? Das ist eine Frage für Stefan, definitiv. Aber ich werde dann auch immer darauf hinweisen, dass du dich da geirrt hattest.
Also, die März-Regierung, mal gucken, ob sie Dienstag noch da ist. Denn die neue Richterin wird ja vorgestellt. Die neue Richterin, Kandidatin. Entweder stellt die SPD jemanden vor, den die niemals akzeptieren. Oder danach ist die SPD tot. Also wir sind, glaube ich, ganz gut Dienstag verabredet. Es sind jetzt zwei Tage. Gucken wir mal gucken, was passiert. Drei Tage.
Hier wird gefragt, ja oder nein, schon mal von Danilo Dolci gehört. Was ist das?
Keine Ahnung. Wer kennt sich aus?
Muss man das kennen? Aber es gibt keine großen Reaktionen.
Welche Tageszeitung hat derzeit das beste Föhton? Wenn überhaupt, steht in Klammern.
Ja, ich lese ja fast nur noch Handelsblatt. Die haben kein Föhton. Ich würde ja doch am Ende und nicht, weil wir in Frankfurt sind, sondern generell sagen, doch am meisten findet man da noch eher im FAZ-Föhton, oder?
Ja, würde ich auch sagen.
Auch wenn wir da gar nicht mehr so drin sind. Wolfgang, welchen Kinofilm müsste man in Deutschland mal drehen? Na ja gut, da würde sich wahrscheinlich vieles anbieten. Aber ich habe jetzt nicht so eine konkrete Vision. Den Film hätte ich jetzt mal. Also ich will jetzt nicht Pretty Woman auf Deutsch reden, mit Veronica Ferris oder so. Insofern, ich glaube, man sollte generell mutigere Filme drehen.
Ja, hier ist eine Frage, die zielt schon auf den Salon ab. Erleben wir gerade, wie der Generationenvertrag von der Jugend aufgekündigt wird, da sie zunehmend Parteien wählen, die das System, in Anführungszeichen, ändern wollen? Glaub mal, auf AfD Linke. Also ich saß ja mal im Presseclub und habe gesagt, das Wahlprogramm der CDU ist ein Abschiedsbrief an die Jugend. Jetzt muss man eigentlich nur darauf warten, wie die darauf reagieren. Weil sie sagen, wer seid ihr? Keine Ahnung. Ich wähle euch nicht. Ich sehe euch ja auch gar nicht. Und da die Linken ja gerade, wie wir auch hier gehört haben, ein Angebot machen, das System tatsächlich ändern zu wollen, was glaube ich sehr attraktiv für junge Leute ist, denn es bietet ihnen kaum etwas. Keine Ahnung. Ich finde nur Generationenvertrag. Das klingt immer so, als hätte da jemand was unterschrieben, als wären wir da nicht zwangsweise.
Wie könnte der Journalismus in Deutschland weniger polarisierend sein? Die Frage ist natürlich an sich interessant, deshalb, weil wir ja über Polarisierung, das wissen jetzt die im Saal noch nicht, sprechen werden. Wir nehmen das quasi mit, diese Frage, denn wir reden im nächsten Salon über zwei Bücher, die sich mit dem Thema Polarisierung beschäftigen. Eines wird sagen, Polarisierung ist gar nicht so schlecht und das andere sagt, man muss diese Spaltung überwinden.
Ja, also ich habe keinen Ansinnen, dass es weniger polarisierend ist. Es muss ja mehr polarisierend sein. An beide. Als Lehrerin stelle ich mir manchmal die Frage, das mit dem manchmal ist gut, ob nicht zu viel Verantwortung auf Schulen abgewälzt wird. Auch im Bereich Freespeech, der Alltag in der Schule ist krass. Ja, der Alltag bei uns in der Schule ist auch krass und das sage ich, obwohl ich ihn gar nicht mitbekomme, denn man hört ja kaum was aus der Schule, aber das, was man dann hört, ist crazy. Von daher würde ich sagen, ja.
Ja, also das ist auch das Problem.
Die Schulen haben auf jeden Fall zu viel Verantwortung. Ich bin ja großer Fan von Alfred Adler, ist natürlich so ein individualpsychologisches Konzept der Aufgabenteilung, die da drin steckt, aber hier müssen mal Aufgaben neu verteilt werden. Und ich finde, solange in Tagesthemsendungen abends 22.30 Uhr immer noch so ein Wagen mit Essen hinten durchs Bild fährt, nur weil im Bundestag mal eine Pressekonferenz stattfindet, können wir in dieser Art von Bewirtung und Beförderung, also solange das in der Schule nicht da ist, haben die zu viel Verantwortung für Aufgaben, die sie eigentlich nicht erfüllen müssen.
Ja. Interessante Frage. Wie hoch schätzt ihr den Anteil von FDP-Wählern im Saal ein? In Klammern, ich weiß von einem.
Ich auch, ich weiß von einher.
Okay, also es sind mindestens zwei. Vielleicht können die sich nachher noch treffen.
Ich weiß von zwei.
Ach du lieber Gott. Wen hast du denn alles eingeladen?
Ich weiß Bescheid über euch.
So, jetzt finde ich sehr gespannt diese Frage.
Warte, hier ist das eine. An Wolfgang, Bahn fahren ohne Smartphone, wie geht das? Die Frage muss sich jeder beantworten, weil was nützt das Smartphone und Internet?
Ich habe es folgendermaßen ja immer gemacht. Ich habe das Bahnticket zuhause ausgedruckt, in eine Klarsichtfolie gelegt und dann bin ich damit los. Bedeutete aber, wenn sich da irgendwelche Anschlüsse verändern, stand ich dann oft sehr hilflos da, musste mir dann oft von wesentlich älteren Leuten auf dem Smartphone zeigen lassen, wo es langgeht. Und irgendwann habe ich die Demütigung nicht mehr ausgehalten. Und außerdem muss dieser Einser eben mit Smartphone betrieben werden. Was sind eure Gedanken zu polyamorösen Beziehungskonzepten? Gibt es Erfahrungswerte?
Also, ich habe in der Kinderwüste ganz ausführlich darüber geschrieben, wie ich mir das vorstelle. Denn hier in der Oper sprach Michel Friedmann mit Katharina, no, not Katharina, Katinka Schweizer, die seit 30 Jahren Paare berät, Psycho-Dingsinstitute führt und so weiter. Und hat sie gefragt, ja, aber was ist denn mit diesem Vertrauens- und so weiter Verhältnis, wenn man doch vielleicht mehr diese Art von Eifersucht vermuten sollte, wenn sich Leute mit anderen Leuten so intensiv unterhalten, dass sie ihr Herz ausschütten und so weiter. Da kommt doch eigentlich eine körperliche Sache gar nicht mit. Und darauf konnte sie überhaupt gar nicht antworten. Also, dass es Michael Friedmann wirklich genervt hat. Und seitdem treibt mich diese Frage auch rum. Von daher denke ich mir, was ist denn hier mit polyamorös gemeint? Nur diese körperliche Komponente oder dieses, was Friedmann eben meinte. Und da das nie spezifiziert ist, kann ich darauf nicht antworten.
Ja, das war eine sehr lange Antwort.
Du kannst auch auf die Frage antworten.
Weil ich gar nicht groß ergänzen will. Ich bin da ziemlich altmodisch. Deswegen sind so, ich bin doch eher so exklusiv zu haben.
Was bist du?
Exklusiv.
Exklusiv. Wird durch KI demnächst die Unterscheidung, die Frage ist sehr gut. Eigentlich haben wir sie gerade schon beantwortet. Ich stelle sie jetzt. Wird durch KI demnächst die Unterscheidung zwischen Medienprofis und im besten Fall gut recherchierten Nachrichten und Medienarten schwierig und problematisiert. Problematisiert oder irgendwie so. Also ich denke mir, wenn mir Gemini nicht nur besseres Fact-Checking bietet, sondern auch auf die gestellten Fragen an die Politiker besser antworten, also ich sogar die Politiker Antworten rausstreichen kann aus meinem Medienprogramm, plus alle Leute, die da auf der Terrasse rumstehen und irgendwie und man weiß gar nicht, was sie da tun, ist das völlig entschieden. Also im Social Media-Zeit, alter, war es schon schwierig, Journalismus zu rechtfertigen. Jetzt ist es, also ich weiß gar nicht, warum es das noch gibt, was wir hier gerade geguckt haben.
Was war vorher in der orangefarbenen Bräuninger Tasche, die da steht? Anzug für 1500 Euro? Ich besitze überhaupt gar keinen Anzug für 1500 Euro. Dort war ein Parfum drin von Tom Ford. Und das hat dazu geführt, dass ich heute, als ich ins Uber stieg, der Mann sagte, sehr guter Duft, darf ich raten. Und er hat es gleich erraten.
Profis. Erleben wir das Ende der Technokratie? Nein.
Eher den Anfang oder die Fortführung?
So, ich habe jetzt noch eine.
Ja, bitte.
Das war es ja dann, eine noch.
Na, ich wollte mir hier noch wissen, was wir auf der Bühne naschen. Ich nasche da gar nichts, aber das sind Erdnüsse. Stefan hat bestimmt davon genascht.
Die standen hier einfach.
Dann hier noch eine Frage. Auch für uns interessant. Mehrwertsteuer auf Bücher abschaffen. Ja, ist ja sowieso vermindert. Also sieben Prozent könnte man ganz abschaffen. Welche Ansicht dafür?
Ich würde Mehrwertsteuer auf einiges abschaffen. When does this come before a few episodes of in-viewed-competitions? Haben wir eins in Aussicht gestellt?
Ja, ich habe mich da mal dummerweise weiter vorgewagt.
Dann sollten wir es machen.
Hattest du aber doch mir zur Kenntnis gegeben, dass du da sehr fit bist. Insofern müssen wir also noch ein paar Jahre Training hinter uns bringen.
Das wird nämlich in den nächsten Jahren besser.
Dann vielleicht wird es besser. Ja, die letzte Frage kommt ein bisschen unvermittelt. Hier steht einfach drauf Steuererklärung. Und ich frage mich, ob das irgendein Hinweis sein soll auf etwas.
Wir treffen gleich unseren ehemaligen Steuerberater.
Hast du da noch irgendwas zu sagen? Bist du hier irgendwie säumig? Und deswegen hat man das hier schon zugespielt?
Ich bin schon säumig. But it's all in the making.
Gut, dann...
Ja, das ist er. Komm, eine noch.
Eine letzte Frage. Ja, das ist jetzt alles so. Das sind so Fragen, die so ganz weit gehen. Also, was wir von irgendeinem Paidler halten.
Wenn dieser Finger unten ist, kommt das Intro.
Wir... Ja, okay, ich hab noch was. Hallo, ihr Lieben. Was wäre euer letztes Mal? Also das letzte Mal, was wir essen, nicht? Das, ne? Also nicht anders zu verstehen. Und uns wird hier in Klammern noch ausgeführt, das würde Vorspeise, Hauptspeise und Dessert beinhalten.
Okay, sag du sie zuerst.
Bei mir wäre es so, dass ich eine Tomatencreme Suppe nehmen würde. Und ich würde dann wahrscheinlich momentan es sich unglaublich gern zu Trüffelpasta greifen. Und dann wäre aber auch wirklich gut, denn Dessert mag ich eigentlich gar nicht.
Ja, also ich hätte gerne noch mal diese Wagner-Pizza Hawaii, die es früher gab, als ich Schüler war. Die gibt's einfach nicht mehr. Aber jetzt, da ich ein paar Sachen kennengelernt habe, würde ich sagen, ich würde mir diesen Heilbrot, den ich immer noch essen wollte, aufheben. Für mein letztes Mal. In 40 Jahren dann.
So Gott will. Einen schönen Abend. Bis zum nächsten Mal. Schön, dass ihr da wart. Bis bald.